[Music]
it's the bootleg
podcast man we got the homie j mills
yeah yeah yeah yeah what's up man
welcome sir
what up what up um all right man you got
a new project that's officially out
we're paying the walls by the time this
is out it'll be out
yeah we're painting the walls wood
painted walls wood panel
with panel walls yeah so was that what's
that like in a car you get the wood
panel
you know what it is it's like uh i grew
up in new york city in western heights
so a lot of those apartments was the
architecture was real
old school it might have like oh i know
the kind of walls you're talking about
yeah it might have like
five six rooms but when you first come
in it's a long hallway
but it'll be a room on this side then a
room here then a kitchen then the room
here then
so my grandmother had one of those
apartments right and when i was born
i was living in my grandma's crib she
from down south
right had 11 kids so the house was very
busy
but i'm a virgo so my memory bank
is incredible like i can remember things
that
i probably shouldn't remember and i
didn't even try to remember right right
right right but the wood pin
wall [ __ ] is stuck out you know what i'm
saying like rest in peace to my
grandmom's
they have those in trailers too yeah
they got him in trouble in my uncle's
trailer it's like wood but it's not real
wood
yeah is that what used to be on side of
like the station wagons too
yeah i think so you know griswold ride
mm-hmm wildly world vibes it's old
school
yeah it sounded like that like three
think like three's company like
you know you got the little i know right
and my grandmom's crib was
all like that so when i went to do this
project
kind of like what we was talking about
the other day i
i've come from an era of the radio
record
the street single right to this record
you know what i'm saying so this was the
first time i was like man [ __ ] all that
let me just record
let me record a story you know i got so
many stories so many memories let me
just record some [ __ ]
that i could paint a picture from track
one to track
whatever's gonna be the last one no
radio records it ain't no party [ __ ] no
strip club [ __ ]
it ain't really too much with a bounce
but if you listen to it from beginning
to end
it's a good story now i first uh
knew of you from your battling days yeah
way back in the day
well not even that bad yeah smackdown
it's a long time now we're getting we
getting
the years are going like i didn't even
know you just battled e-ness again
recently because i remember the original
yeah shout-out to shout out to nes you
know that was a rbe situation
he was in the band right yeah he was in
the band and this is a big thing people
don't know
he was the only one that was dope in
there i think people i think
that chopper dude was horrible i think
people think i was trying to be a part
of the band
like i never was auditioning for the
band i was never trying to be in the
band it was just really like did he call
me and hit a battle nest
that's really all it was i wasn't that
was probably like was that like the
first like like your biggest look at the
time was to
do at that time that might have been my
biggest look
i was still doing like street but i
don't know if i had no no no out yet i
don't think i had
i don't know if i had to warn a
brother's deal yet i think i was still
doing like battling
mixtape type [ __ ] but yeah i mean coming
i mean obviously
you go from the battle world where
you're like a legend
um and then you you had the no no no
record i remember
having that right now yeah yeah um but
then there's like a whole other wave of
people who
just know you from being from young
money so
you and wayne and and the young money
situation
uh how like when did that start and how
did it initially happen because at the
time it was what just you and nicky they
were from the east coast
uh they were from new york it was me and
nikki but he was [ __ ] with corey guns
too shout out oh yeah yeah yeah boy i
mean
i don't know if guns was i don't know if
guns i don't think he ever signed
officially but he was i don't know if he
was signed or whatever yeah but i
remember he had the milli remix yeah
yeah and he was [ __ ] with guns i feel
like he was on the original
yeah yeah yeah guns guns might have been
around young money before me
okay guns and nicki might have been
around young money before me but nothing
was really
solidified nikki was definitely around
around but me and guns was kind of like
wayne just [ __ ] with us he just liked
that rapping type [ __ ] but
yeah that was that was that situation i
think around the time i started [ __ ]
with wayne might have been like
2007. i want to say like 2007 because
this is the situation with me and wayne
i'm explaining this i had a song called
highlighter player
and i don't know if people knew or not
but i wasn't
assigned to universal no more this is
like when silvia roan came over and
everything changed like and
you know like i said i'm from the radio
era i'm from that era of the single and
all of these [ __ ] so i'm trying to just
keep my record going cause i know i
don't got no deal no more right
right so i'm doing [ __ ] like
this is in oh six i'm doing [ __ ] like
recording myself taking the curses out
and texting dj enough or dj camilla or
kate slade like or flex
like yo i got this new record now this
is usually coming from a department
yeah the raptor record rep yeah now it's
like you sending me this [ __ ] directly
well all right cool
we [ __ ] with you so yeah just send it
and now
i started getting radio play and i'm
like damn
i'm noticing i'm getting play like mick
show play twice a day you might get the
rush hour play you might get the traffic
hour
traffic jam play seven o'clock play you
know later on
somebody's come on at 12. i might have
heard my [ __ ] four or five times today i
got no deal
i'm in my mom's crib real [ __ ]
and i'm like i can't go on to another
record i'm smart enough to know that
i cannot go into another record i got
something going right now
so i hit wayne right
so i'm like uh i got this record
you know what i'm saying is this
bubbling in new york right now if you
want to jump on it i sent it to you
i'm really just taking a shot in the
dark oh i don't know if he's going to
get on this [ __ ] or not but
i had a record called bring it back with
jadakiss
and then i did a remix with wayne and
fab
wayne said come to the studio now now
shout out to fab shout out to kiss you
know what i'm saying granted they was
they busy but wayne told me come to the
studio
and did it that night and then charged
me nothing then
this is when he doing like 300 records
in right so in my mind i'm like
i'm just taking i'm shooting from half
court
in a dark gym on all of these moves
right now i don't know what's gonna
happen
send him the record he send the record
back next day
so my brother is like the super lil
wayne fan at this time
he like bro i heard that verse before
i'm like no he just did this verse for
me last night
he said not bro i heard that verse
before i'm gonna be real with you like
he didn't want to say it like that but
he's like he pulled the verse up like
it's mixtape weezy
all sorts of egg all on my face now so
now i'm faced with the decision do i
act like i do not know that this man
said this verse already
and still put this song out well can i
just hit him
and just be like yo i appreciate it but
i can't put this out you know blah blah
he was like oh my [ __ ] next day
sent me another verse back and said some
[ __ ] in the joint like mills had to tell
me stop recycling
verses and since i don't write it i
recite it in cursive
i was like oh that's personalized for me
that ain't like
right he just gave me a verse from some
a dedication mixtape that didn't come
out right right
right so now i'm like oh that shot you
took in the dark gym
you hit the rim on that [ __ ] like you
might just stay in this dark gym a
little more but just try to get closer
to where you hit the rim at
so now i'm like yo look man i ain't got
no situation i know you're doing the
young money [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying if i could come play some music
he said you got no deal
call you right back so i'm like oh i'm
done on that verse
i'm like that versus a dub he's not i'm
i don't got no budget i don't
he knows now i don't have money to give
him for the verse
he called me back with ted's on the
phone he's like when can you get on the
flight
he said but tell me this again you said
you don't have no vert no deal right i
said nah
he said when can you get on a flight to
miami now i'm in harlem
i'm like i get on the flight yesterday
he started laughing
after that flight i was young money
until i wasn't young money no more
yeah i mean so that was 0.6 that was
like oh that's around 0.607
it was around it was right before you
know how right before car was carter
three was right before the
three when i got around i remember the
first time i he flew me out
after that conversation i went to the
hit factory when he walked in he started
just playing me a bunch of music and
[ __ ]
and i remember he played lollipop i'll
never forget this [ __ ]
this is when i was like oh yeah i gotta
step my [ __ ] up a whole lot like
that i'm a nice rapper that's a huge
wreck i was like i'm a good rapper
he's a a great artist yeah and i have no
problem doing it
i have no problem with saying that
because wayne is my man i love wayne
unconditionally he showed me [ __ ]
that no other friend showed me no of a
homie no of a businessman
or a ceo nor a rapper he showed me and
he was hard on me with that [ __ ] too but
i learned a lot so
i'm like i'm like damn what the [ __ ] is
this but
it sounded like the t-pain t-pain was
killing everything at this time
but now i'm i know wayne from uh
i'm like damn how you do that [ __ ] like
now he playing me a
bunch of [ __ ] he played me got money now
i had had to beat forgot money from
playing skills
or they had played me like you know
beating that game in the beat so i knew
i was like oh i heard this [ __ ] before
all right let me just sit here and
listen to his version i was like oh [ __ ]
he got t-pain on it that's
that's the plan that they played when
they played me the song like oh he
i was like well i wouldn't have never
made this song like this right glad they
didn't get his [ __ ] to me
it's like i'm so glad they didn't waste
this record with me because i wouldn't
have never made this
this you know what i'm saying so carter
three wasn't out yet he was still doing
like
college arenas and [ __ ] like that yeah
it wasn't like
that i am music and then like
a lot of the carter three leaked he was
still performing a lot of the leak [ __ ]
he was still performing
were you around when the music leaked or
had it already been to leaked around i
was still like
just doing my and like i wasn't on
universal yeah because i just remember
like
being up because i used to slang [ __ ] at
the swap meet that's not
my name so i remember just having
everything little wayne taste like
there was like carter three [ __ ]
leaks the drought
the droughts and then it was like i mean
obviously before that
the squad up [ __ ] but like that that
like era like right before carter three
like the like 12 months prior when he
was just heating up this the mixtape
[ __ ] it was like
that's what really got wayne hot up top
i mean he was already hot since he was
[ __ ] 13 14.
now but i mean like behind like
reinventing himself from being like lil
wheezy to like the fireman well no one
took lil wayne like serious
no but he had to start saying i'm the
best rapper alive since the best rapper
retired
because he had this stunt he had to make
that statement and then he just
started and then i remember he performed
on the bt awards he performed gossip
mm-hmm oh yeah yeah yeah yeah stop
hating on a [ __ ] that
no hey
once i got around him that's what made
me realize oh [ __ ] i remember that i was
like oh this is the first single for
carter three and then uh
he didn't he was one of them type people
when songs leak him
he like like he called those dead homies
he was i mean yeah what he did with uh
because you know being the youngest dude
in cash money
i feel like as a rapper there wasn't a
lot of people with credibility that
probably took him serious
until the first quarter when he started
popping his [ __ ]
that's that's around the time because
500 degrees was whatever
i mean i think the block is hot was dope
i think if you really were a cash money
fan you knew little wayne could rap
yeah but like people like like you said
like once that first carter came out i
remember working at best buy man when
that [ __ ] dropped that [ __ ] was
i remember the first time i heard being
uh bm jr
mm-hmm he's got to put his feet in the
blades
i ain't tripping [ __ ] i play the corner
like ripken [ __ ] with the 40k
i was like yeah here in a different
world but carter two
was was when because by this time i'm
deep in
rap i'm deep i'm an artist i don't have
my ups my downs i don't my
my high points my low points i read
credits i read magazines i just want to
know people that go to school late
when i'm walking in the lunchroom with
the source magazine the double xl the
blaze i might have a vibe
right somebody blaze magazine yeah i
might have had [ __ ] the freestyles of
people get your tape decks ready last
night on dj clue the [ __ ] fire truck
right i was that type of kid so when i
heard carter two
i'm like oh [ __ ] this is the first time
i heard a wayne album with no mini fresh
production
and it was dope now i get to hear him
compare to
everybody else now now damn he rapping
over the heat makers
who the [ __ ] are the runners right you
know what i'm saying so
around that time i got with wayne that
[ __ ] showed me a lot it was it
to bring it back full circle it was
around that time
right before carter three that's around
the time i got with young money help me
understand
uh okay so
young money there's obviously
the product of young money is two of the
biggest artists of all time
drake and nikki but there was all these
other rappers
so many let's talk about it there was
you there was gutta gutta
i mean you know mac main was the
president but you know macmillan was a
rapper
shout out to him shout out to matt i'm
surprised mac never got a solo album off
yeah
doing some funny [ __ ] when i first came
around young money
i remember mac was telling me then like
i want to be on some [ __ ]
yeah like [ __ ] all this rapping like he
was tired of it then
hey i'm looking at it like bro you i
used to i used to send him so much [ __ ]
yo let's get on this beat let's because
i was i'm a fan of magma here i'm a fan
of the squad i'm a fan of wayne so i
wanted to just do
all sorts of [ __ ] with everybody and
then i was the person that used to
when wayne would fly me out i would
bring my inbox
and my computer my m audio speakers
in the hotel room that he has me in i
would never go to the bus where he's at
i would just be in the room
just recording and i remember one day i
think gutter or twist told him he's like
what mail's out and he's like oh he's
upstairs recording
he's like what are you doing recording
yourself
promise you the next day i came
downstairs on wayne's tour bus he had
all that [ __ ]
learned how to record himself oh wow
quick quick
oh but no but we're we're talking like a
vast amount of artists
like you just said little chucky chucky
twists uh
chanel she now had the music the
piercing right me
guns so many people and it seemed
tiger tiger nicki drake it just seemed
like
uh being on young money could be more
too that's the crazy part
a lot more but it could be perceived to
be a gift and a curse
t street shout out my man c street
streets but like what
why do you think uh it didn't work out
for everybody
and by everybody i mean the majority of
the artists on the label i tell people
this all the time
it never works out for everybody once
you understand that
it's like and i'm looking at this
picture of charles barkley right now and
he's taking me somewhere right
i want to explain people something there
was a lot of great people on the sixers
when barclay came a lot of great people
uh on the lakers when kobe came
i always tell you what's there i always
tell people
i know what it feels like to be eddie
jones
hmm i know what it feels like to be
eddie jones not saying that
i'm not nice well i'm not great hey
jones not but i know what it was like to
be
great and somebody comes around and they
are
undeniable you can go in the studio and
make the dopest [ __ ] you want
aubrey is undeniable i remember the
first time wayne let me hear successful
i was like whoa this [ __ ] is dope the
next time i heard it wayne had a
different verse
i said why you got a different version
so i sent it to drake and he said he
didn't really
he liked the verse but he didn't really
think it went with the concept of the
song i said he made you do a verse over
damn you know what i'm saying but and
but it showed me the respect
wayne had for that right yeah because he
did the same thing for me
um he did the same thing for me yeah get
it over i respect
you you know what you're right you know
what i'm saying so
that just brings me back to the whole it
was a lot of artists what happened it
was a lot of artists on
cash money there's a lot of artists on
no limit a lot of artists on death row
but i remember
snoop pop and the dog pound
not saying lady of rage or jewell or or
crook
or or you know it's not to say that it
wasn't great crook was a part of it
after like the dark the dark years of
death it's not to say that they wasn't
great
but nikki was undeniable
drake was undeniable out of let's say if
it was 10 of us
because it was all it was like 10 10 11
of us it was a lot
to hit with three the way that you hit
now some people might say mills you're
being a little too cordial about that my
[ __ ] because you wasn't one of those
three
it's how i work sometimes keep it moving
figure it out
that wasn't my first
already so this isn't new to me i know
that this [ __ ] ain't gonna last forever
and i feel like a lot of people
they thought it was gonna last forever i
think with tiger
he had been around he had been with gym
class heroes he had coconut milk
how to make this [ __ ] work drake had
already been come back season
i would almost argue that that tiger
popped despite lil wayne he did
wayne tune i love you i love you toon
all right tiger will tell you this wayne
didn't like that direction that tiger
was going in
like make it nasty rack city [ __ ]
better have my money dancing for them
dollars right
uh what was the joint he had ass so
fat needed a lap dan wasn't feeling
because
you gotta understand that's not the
vision wayne saw for him when he first
met him you tiger tiger you
know bouncy flow like kind of like some
souls of mischief type [ __ ]
you different you like a real west coast
lyrical
crafty with your words and now you going
strip club
on me they don't even really have strip
clubs where you act like that
like where this coming from it was kind
of like
when i used to first got around young
money you listened to dedication three
my boss was like
on top of each other on top of each
other even anytime i did mixtapes with
young money
my boss was on top of each other like
that and that's because wayne taught me
how to
differentiate it she ain't got a man
but she's not alone miss independent yes
she got her own
hey i hated that verse that was the end
of my verse
wayne said now you know what i think you
should start the verse off like that
because that's more like
that's a memorable and i'm just like i
don't care
i was more into i got a [ __ ] named
keisha from around the way
she used to go to college school back in
the day he was like oh [ __ ] that's dope
that's why he just wanted me to talk
crazy all day because in his mind his
vision for me was
they already know you for talking crazy
you said big in my trouble or what and
i put a gun in your face we love you for
that
so you get a pass to do that because a
little chucky and a little twist can't
do that
they're not known for that they got to
be kids still you know what i'm saying
so
he had visions for all of us he never
really wanted all of us to be like
signed to young money he wanted us to be
young money a group and we do some
wu-tang [ __ ] and all get deals
i know this sounds like crazy this
sounds like
yeah right mills he did he never really
wanted us all to be signed
to him he wanted to give us a platform
and we go rep young money
and get deals and bags everywhere but we
still like this
[ __ ] conglomerate on some [ __ ]
because in his mind
the hot boys was all solo artists true
so like if they if birdman could put me
in the studio
with bg and juvenile i don't want to
hear y'all
say nothing about me putting y'all in
the studio a little chucking a little
twist yeah man i mean
we'll check in a little twist god bless
him look there was some time that we
drop off there were some times that we
was like
tuned check this out bro we love you man
we love you but come on man it's 5 45
a.m man it's beeping looping for
we don't really want to do this but but
i knew that a lot of see me
i knew a lot of the [ __ ] that wayne used
to do to us was a test it was like boot
camp it's a lot of y'all i need to see
who really wanted
right you know what i'm saying i need to
see who gonna go
hard like it ain't really about who nice
you could be dead nice but you might be
lazy
was there ever like there's hell of
rumors of internal issues with
people in young money i mean uh
did you you said chucky and twist didn't
get along
it was internal issues everywhere but
not like
not like not like beef like chucky and
swiss had they thing because
they was like they could only be one kid
they were kids
it was like the kid who's the who's the
young money youngin who's the prince of
young money
and then chanel and nikki they never had
a thing
but to me it felt like it because it's
like well who's the first lady of young
money yeah i mean that was pretty
evident
no not in the beginning it wasn't not in
the beginning really when we all
used to have to do group photo shoots
and [ __ ] like that
you got to remember nikki was coming
from come up dvd
chanel was coming from being a
songwriter and a dancer for neo
two different things totally different
at that time i'm talking about
10 years ago right you know what i'm
saying it was a different thing like
drake wasn't what he is now he was like
coming from
degrassi he was more known for degrassi
than people respected him as a rapper
it took a very long time for people to
respect drake as a rapper but i think it
was so much music
he was in that digital era that once you
got so far gone he was like
yeah no he was [ __ ] incredible but
you just didn't want to say
he was incredible because it's like well
damn wayne's still incredible
then after a while it's like well who's
more incredible then after a while it's
like
damn nikki kind of hot too and then you
kind of for
tiger i feel like tiger was the first
one to get lost in there when i seen
tiger get lost in there i said it's bad
for me
um that's real [ __ ] i'm gonna keep it a
buck i said it's bad for me
bad for you what do you mean because
tiger had a setup
right he had any i don't know if that
time he was managed by jay irvin
i don't know t don't don't kill me for
this i don't really know the specifics
of it but i remember
i remember me and gutter used to talk a
lot me and goddess i talked spoke to the
god of god over there shout out to god
shout out to the whole young money
period uh
um me and gutter used to talk a lot
right
about just the way [ __ ] was going
because
gutter used to he was around before me
and when i first got the young money
wayne told me if you want to know how to
stay around me
like how to if you really want to know
me stick to him
he told me i remember when i first came
around he was like he's like he knows me
you know what i'm saying if you if you
want to know me you want to know
how not to get on my bad side how not to
you know what i'm saying how to move
around me
stick to him you know what i'm saying
and to this day i still talk to god
together right right you know what i'm
saying
he's not on young money anymore yeah
he's so young they got
they got a record out right now i think
it's wayne
gutter and hood called nfl it's for like
the prime video for thursday night
football it's like the song
for some dope [ __ ] uh but basically
bring it to bring it back gutter was
like
how you think this [ __ ] gonna go for us
smells and i was like
it's a chain i was like at the end of
the day drake is undeniable nicky
undeniable we don't know who going
come first out of them and then wayne
went to jail in the midst of them being
like
like floating yeah so by the time he
came out of jail
nicki was pink wig marge simpson it was
like you know and drake was
aston martin music and he was he was he
was they was coming into their own
and then i remember six foot seven and
then wayne was right back to being wayne
and then it was like damn now it's like
big three
right right right right but tyga me and
gutter used to always be like damn tiger
putting in work i would come out here to
cali to see my lady and right right you
know i had kid on the way at that time
and i'll be like tyga keep a song on the
radio now maybe
we in miami or new york we might not
hear that [ __ ] like that
but when i used to come here before i
moved here and i moved in 2015 so this
is like
11 12 13 whatever yeah i call it his
molly mall era when he was in vegas with
molly mo
he was hit there was a [ __ ] called strip
pop going up and there was i think
that's where a lot of them
was he was hit and he was like branding
himself in that lane of like
bop that dj he was brandon
i mean rock city low key is the record
that really blew muscles and feel like
they was like it felt like he was
forcing the hand
like you got it now you gotta and i felt
like damn if he gotta force the hand
you know what i'm saying i'm like i got
to figure some [ __ ] out you know what
i'm saying
i was throwing [ __ ] i'm trying to figure
[ __ ] out but you got to remember in the
midst of that
wayne is wayne drake
is drake and he's only coming bigger
nicki is nikki and the barbie is only
becoming bigger
so now we got to sustain this
we got to sustain wayne nicky drake
tiger's doing his thing but the they're
keeping the lights on nikki and drake
kept the lights on
when wayne went to rikers island keeping
it a buck right
so now all right now we're touring
all right well how do we do the tours
now whoa who's gonna open who's gonna
close who's gonna open who gonna close
or
oh he's not going out with us he's going
out on his own or she's doing her own
tour
she's take so now i'm peeping like
this when i realized
this [ __ ] is really really different and
it happened fast i remember drake did
club paradise that was the name of drake
yeah victoria
i was hot
what were you hot about i loved drake
but i was hot
i think me and i think me and gutter
gutter might have been i don't know if
gutter was too hot
but i was hot and i think i was hot
because i was thinking something was
gonna go a certain way
like did you think you were supposed to
be on the tour yes
i will come exactly was that the
kendrick asap rocky tour that was every
that was
that was basically everybody that was
doing the same thing that we were doing
at that time that wasn't with young
money
i remember that i remember and i love
drake
i ain't gonna lie i love drake with all
my heart man i love nikki i love tiger
wayne gutter mac main twist i love all
the everybody that was a part of that
ride
with young money whether we still cause
me and tyga not young money no more but
i always
i'm not covering my young money tattoo
like i still sign my checks and you
still see it
because that was a decade of my life
that was a that was like a real period
of my life
but there were a lot of times that in
that period i started to see
oh we're label mates we homies
but we're we're label mates and you
can't you can't forget that because
you didn't grow up with these people you
met these people on some
business [ __ ] so
your laker reference people get traded
people people get traded
but at this time we still got the same
uniform on right so i'm looking at it
like
damn i would have thought we could at
least open up
you know what i'm saying like though
take us out there like tune took you
or or nicky too
you know what i'm saying like take us
out there like you took dead loaf
or this one in this one even if we not
hot like that make us hot somebody made
you hot
now once again to be fair to be fair
this is just me and my feelings at that
time
as a i'm in younger feelings cause i'm
like yo we crew
we we didn't both had to go chase
the tour people around for pedium before
like
did you communicate that to drake or did
drake ever like know that you
you were once again what i'm saying is
at that time
we were in our feelings about [ __ ] i'm
saying that he find out jake might have
been in his feelings about [ __ ] with us
that we don't know about you know he
might have been in his feelings with
[ __ ] about
wayne or tez or you know i'm saying
there was times that
wayne might have been in his feelings
with some [ __ ] about ted's and drake
might have paid for it
you know what i'm saying like it might
have been sometimes that
wayne was he just wasn't [ __ ] with
new york and when i walk in the room
it's just like
[ __ ] old new york ass [ __ ] no it's
not like the end of the world it's not
in person but
you got to think when you around people
as long as we was around each other
young money [ __ ] was a long ride that
[ __ ] wasn't like no
two three year you hot and then you hear
it's like nah we all went from one bus
we was all on wayne bus to now it's
wayne bus
and an artist bus now we all on the
artist bus to now it's wayne buster
artist bus drake bus nicki busted band
bust the dancers bus
the chef bust the crew like that [ __ ]
changed i went from doing clubs to
performing in front of when i say j you
say mills jay
jay where you at milsie and my my [ __ ]
come on and i'm like damn i never heard
people scream for me like that
right so it was a hell of a ride but in
in along that ride you did learn [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying you did learn
that yo drake don't got to do nothing
for you
right nothing now once i got that
through my head
i was cool it's like yo i don't know i'm
not tripping if he come out with
six or seven albums and i'm not on none
of them i could still find the dopeness
in the [ __ ] album it's like it's cool
bro
it's not the end of the world if
somebody don't
pull you along like especially if you
never told me you was gonna pull me
along and you
it's all in your head you know what i'm
saying did you ever help wayne with any
writing because there was no and this is
a thing too i want because there was
like
there's there's been a lot of rumors
about like gilly used to write for him
and well i wasn't around for that i
wasn't around for the gilly but i mean
like
i don't really you got a lethal pen like
did he ever tap in with you for some
bars i will say this
it's been many times that we in the
studio and wayne might be like
yo tell me what you think of this yo
okay
but yeah like that's what i got for
right now but i feel like that's natural
that's like any studio
i will go downstairs in the studio with
wayne and be like
yo this i got i got like 12 but i don't
know if i should do a 16 or 12 but
this is what i got i wanted to say this
next but i don't know how that [ __ ]
sound like well you could say that but
if you flip it
this way and just say it like this so
that mean wayne wrote for me now
no it's just it's just i feel like
that's just because i watched kanye west
going in the studio
kanye kanye play lucifer for jay-z
and say i'm from the murder capital
where we murder for capitals
if you don't use this i'm gonna use this
for my album and then jay-z got on there
and said i gotta get these devils out my
life
and then cut it off and said oh my god i
never read the bible a day in my life
on faith to black he says that i watched
kanye go in there and give him
lucifer and say i'm from the murder
capital where they murder for capitals
jay-z was not from the murder capital
kanye west was but we will never say
kanye west wrote for jay-z
true we will never even with
clear [ __ ] footage
of it in fade to black we will never say
kanye west
wrote for jay-z well why do you think
the drake thing was recepted
so differently i think i think
personally it was because
we heard the references yeah and that's
kind of like
i think with wayne too it was big
because
i think it only comes so heavy like that
when it's somebody you respect
so when gilly said this [ __ ] about wayne
it was like nah wayne been nice since he
was 13.
he ain't even know you then so how you
saying you wrote and i don't think he
was saying it like that i think he was
just saying
there was a time where i was influencing
the way that he rapped now i can
understand that because we're younger
than gilly so
i was a major figures fan too i was on
dutch and spade too
i was on all that [ __ ] like i bought
major figures i
i bought the album you know what i'm
saying i understood gilly was with
schwab house and tony draper and ab lava
before he got was
i was a fan not was am still as a fan of
major figures i still say that it was
dead nice
so i could understand what gilly's
influence he could say like i influenced
all that swag rapping the dragon the
words
but i don't like you wrote like wrote
for him
once again i can't say he didn't but i
could see where he could say he
influenced him
but wayne is so
like articulate with the way he put his
[ __ ] together
he he wants to put it together you know
i'm saying he wants to craft it and put
it together now you could help him
you could tell him no i don't think you
should say you should say it this way
but if i was in here recording something
you might tell me that yo jay i think
you oh yeah that [ __ ] might have been
crazy if you would have said
oh [ __ ] you know what kev you're right
let's do it over i don't mean that
you're
any less of a m you know what i'm saying
i think like you said with the drake
[ __ ] we heard
the references yeah the drake thing when
we heard the references and it's like
that was supposed to be the goats that
was a little crazy supposed to be one of
the greatest of all
time it's the same that was a little
crazy but that's different than what
we're talking about
because what we're talking about is hey
we're in the studio let me help you with
what with the with the drake joint was
it like the same verse and all of that
or was the same like melody of words and
he changed some of the words
it was the same [ __ ] it was the same
hook same verse it was the same [ __ ]
quentin miller man no i know he did it
but i do also think
listen to think that drake isn't
incredible with his pen is an ignorant
thought to have i think drake is like
one of the best artists ever
of course i think of course if we're
having that discussion like in life
everybody included so i just think that
if you're drake you're probably so
[ __ ] busy like he's probably torn
doing all kinds of [ __ ]
and people are sending references and he
might just be like yeah this shit's hot
like let me
like i i personally don't rappers do
that all the time man
i know they do it's just it was him it's
drake
the references came out on because once
again i will always go back to this
like fade to black with kanye west and
jay-z
nobody will ever say kanye west wrote
for jay-z but they'll turn around and
say
somebody wrote for kanye but they won't
give him that same respect and be like
he took a song
into jay-z session said this is the hook
and if you don't use this i'm gonna use
it on my album
and if you go pull up the black album
he word for word said yay [ __ ] that yay
bought him in the studio and we
overlooked it
we overlooked it because drake ain't
jay-z
at that time but drake is up there man
not now
at that time we were still talking about
oh he wrapped on the blackberry on flex
yeah but it was only because you seen
him with the blackberry i know a
million rappers that went up to [ __ ]
master flex show
and their phone is on the speaker but
you can't see it
there's more money people come to our
show all the time don't tell me this
let's just go to something else don't
tell me this i've had artists have their
lyrics on my laptop
in front of them and the laptop's off
why are you doing this man but
to be fair cause you know what's funny
cuz they're gonna know exactly who
you're talking about when they say no no
no
i like one of my boys she's like i'm
cool one of the homies i'm gonna say his
name
really close close friend of mine he
wrote the [ __ ] like when he got to the
stage that's different so that is
different that's different but there's
nothing that's kind of
no he wrote it on the spot that's dope
he literally was like yo uh
throwing a beat and then he he was like
give me like 20 minutes and i'll have
something no that's dope and then he
and then he was like yeah i got
something written that's different i can
respect that yes now
there has been artists that have come in
who literally put their phone on the
thing
and then i got a i'm like because i'm
like i want a good freestyle
so i'm out of camera and i'm literally
with my fingers scrolling down there
burning
as it goes that [ __ ] happens
yeah but this is one thing i do want to
say about the young money [ __ ]
i feel like the way the young money [ __ ]
played out for all of us
believe it or not believe it or not
that was exactly how i was supposed to
play out if i could say
man wayne [ __ ] my [ __ ] up that'd be
different
i can't say wayne [ __ ] my [ __ ] up the
good outweigh the bad
he did more than he didn't do you know
what i'm saying so
i might just say i ain't gonna i was a
little i was a little hot behind club
paradise
that might be the only thing that i
could say i was ever hot behind
right with drake but i could name so
much of a good [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i could say
well nicki never really like
took me on tourney but same way drake
didn't she never really put me on
nothing like that neither but
it stopped it stopped there i can't say
anything else and it's
pain related and those things are me and
my feelings that's artist [ __ ] that's
rapper [ __ ] thinking
ego [ __ ] yeah i wouldn't say ego [ __ ] i
i would say it's feeling like uh
what's the word uh prideful
not prideful feeling like you are
entitled and
entitlement that and that that we
crew so i'm entitled to first dibs on
some
or what you did for that artist you
could have did that for me we crew
that's that entitlement you know what
i'm saying so and not saying that
you partially shouldn't have that
entitlement with your team you know what
i'm saying but
some of it might have just been me
thinking too much but once again
the good outweigh the bad with everybody
so it's not like
that's not changing it's not like oh i
don't follow that name i ain't liking i
don't care about it
i don't care about if she just had kids
don't give a [ __ ] if it's his son's
birthday
it's like bro that [ __ ] was it's not
that serious it's not that deep okay so
you're behind the scenes
i want to know because pusha t is one of
my favorite rappers ever
pusha t has been he was poking and
prodding at lil wayne
for years ever since mr me too which is
for a long time that's prior to you
being with young money that should the
pusha t and
young money or wayne [ __ ] that should go
back way before me
like i just right i just probably only
entertained it because i was young money
at the time yeah because like i'm saying
it it took wayne i want to say it was
maybe
three or four years ago he finally said
push his name on a record
or he's it was i don't remember what he
said he's finally acknowledged pusha t
officially
yeah and i was like wow but like
was that like was that something that
like
like like was a known issue in the crew
like man this [ __ ] these guys over here
man they're [ __ ] disrespectful nah
you know why because wayne being his own
little world so wayne don't really
listen
like he don't really be knowing what be
going on it'd be like me
or gutter or like i gotta tell him to
show him something yeah a little twist
would always come in and show him some
[ __ ] on the laptop
or twitter instagram here big bro look
at this huh so he would be so far into
his music
he wouldn't really know about like the
darts
but when he find out about it it'll be
like a word oh pull that [ __ ] up let me
see that [ __ ]
and then everybody like all the
assistants and managers to be like oh
god mills why did you get them started
i remember we was in the studio
and yay came to play uh ham
uh over the zaytoven production
i
he didn't feel that [ __ ]
uh the damn what was the bar in there
man
i just remembered baby money you got
baby money that ain't my late
something my lady money that's baby
money you got like it was some [ __ ] like
that
wayne walked out the room while kanye's
song's still playing
like just went to go get like a cup of
water and [ __ ]
like yeah that and i remember like
two days later he did a song
was it drake jada kissing wayne was that
carter three
kidnap your [ __ ] kidnap your [ __ ] see
how much you love your lady money
that was carter three no i think that
was that was carter i think it was drake
it might have been it might have been
carter for carter ford was drake
jadakiss and wayne
because watch the throne came out in
2011 it was four four apartment it was
four
i remember i don't remember much from
that album it wasn't good this is when i
liked carter four it just wasn't caught
at three
well yeah it just wasn't caught at three
carter four was fired up it was all
right
uh i remember he was like yo y'all think
that's too much
and everybody was like no i think you
should take that ball out man i don't
think you should really say that
man [ __ ] that [ __ ] say that [ __ ]
everybody got mad at me
as soon as he's like you know what i was
like yo do you feel like
he was talking about you not necessarily
i was like bro this is words it ain't
like you
it ain't like if he was talking about
you
he was that jay who said that yeah it
was jewish
so at this point [ __ ] you you you you
just sold a million
records of course first week came home
and you're about to do it again
this is you you right now if you feel
this is just a battle rapper in me at
this time but this is how much i [ __ ]
with wayne this is
this is what wayne looks at me for you
know what i'm saying
i'm like do you feel like it was a shock
i'm like no cersei do you feel it was a
shot because if you didn't feel it was a
shot you wouldn't have thought of the
ball you thought of
so you asking us for validation to go in
there
to go say what you feel now
you know what you're right he went in
there turn me up
lighter everybody looking at me
yeah cause i do feel like why would you
tell him to do that there was like this
period of time where and i'm like why
not though
i'm like at the end of the day it's
words it's a sport
it's rap it's not like he said i'm gonna
kill you
you felt he said something and you
wanted to say something back do you need
rap
do you feel like that there was some
contention growing between hove and
wayne
i feel like there's some contention
growing between hope and anybody else
that gets hot
to the point where they're on his radar
yeah because i remember i remember that
[ __ ] go back to nas
well there was the rumors that that
wayne was going to leave cash money and
then
signed with rocking rockefeller i
remember that i remember that being a
thing a few different times
and then and then it seemed like even
back before i was with young money i
think wayne and jay
had some business history i think jay
was gonna sign him or
he was gonna give him like a situation
or something that go back wait
it just seemed like and then
what happened jay said in an interview
that he called baby
to let him know they were talking
but then there was like after the carter
three
it felt like there was like this almost
like an unspoken like
like like energy between the two where
it was like wayne was the only guy who
was like challenging hope is that dude
yeah and i felt like that i feel like it
was definitely like was that talked
about
like openly or was it more just like oh
you mean amongst us like
the crew nah we always looked at even
wayne wayne look at jay like jay
you're the goat but wayne his favorite
like person ever is like prince
kobe bryant like if anybody knows wayne
they will tell you mills no wayne off
that
it's prince and kobe bryant michael
jackson is cool but to wayne
michael jackson isn't prince you know
what i'm saying
jordan jordan is cool too but to wayne
yeah kobe could have won seven
you know what i'm saying so it's like
his his mentality is i love
mike but i'm coming at him
and i think that's what it always was
with jay even if you go back to i'm the
best rapper alive
since the best rapper retired and then
once jay-z wasn't retiring no more he
never stopped calling himself the best
rapper alive though he just
kept calling himself it's like are you
back i thought it was my turn i thought
you was retiring
well i'm still i'm still that [ __ ] here
so if you that [ __ ] and i'm
i'm the best though i know you might be
the greatest but i'm the best like right
now i'm the best
and i think wayne just carried that [ __ ]
for so long he carried that [ __ ] for so
long
it's you heard it when you you when you
heard him about to come on a song
you just felt that energy like he just
feel he about to come on he used to tell
us that
right he used to play beats and look at
me and drake and nikki and tiger gutter
whoever was on the song
oh i'm just letting your boys know like
i'm gonna kill all y'all [ __ ] on this
song right now
and turn around and just turn this [ __ ]
all the way back up and light his blood
that's crazy so when you at some point
now we come on the record like that too
now nikki come on i'm a [ __ ]
monster
she come on like i want to kill i don't
think little chucky ever came on a
record like that for the record damn yo
you really don't like chucky
i just thought he was horrible i was
like why these why is he signing these
12 year old children who can't rap
um shout out to chuck and shout out to
twist look the views of bootleg
kev are not the same as nothing to do
with the views of jay mills
yeah not um you know what though i can
respect
no i don't want to see i could respect
because those still my little homies
forever
uh i could understand
a person like you being like nah they
was [ __ ] trash cause they could look
look who they standing next to they
standing next to wayne
drake nikki tyga mills i'm
godly with this lyric if i never put out
an album
with young money i always used to say i
was who i was before i got here i'm
godly i'm gonna let you know me for what
you know me for yeah this can't change
that it can add on
i have plaques for 100 million streams
and i have plaques for four times
platinum two times platinum billboard
peak one peak two peak seven
that that that's more than i had before
i got there true
so the good out way to bed you know i'm
saying a lot of people
they might have loved drake and wayne
but they looked at me how you look that
little chucky in a little twist
oh my god jay mills and gutta gutter was
[ __ ]
horrible they may look at us like that
just like these people that may look at
me and gutter gun and be like nah they
was killing dedication through they held
the
hell a lot of them mixed tapes up when
other artists wasn't
on them shits now um you had said
something to me last week you said you
were around
young money enough to see everyone get
kicked out at least once
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i said that to you i did
i did i did so explain to me
the times in which both nikki and drake
were kicked out of young money because
that seems like an uh
preposterous thing you want to hear you
want to hear the story about
how nikki and drake were once kicked out
it was probably only lasted for about a
day or two
right but or do you want to hear when i
got kicked out of you
all of it which one do you want to hear
first whatever you feel
inclined to i'll give you the nikki and
drake [ __ ] first because they're bigger
names and
that'll probably be more entertaining
for y'all i remember
or i started with nikki nikki if you
remember that one time she was managed
by deb
uh wacker moms yep yeah and deb had her
work and had her out there with gucci
and
you know i think dad was managing french
at that time so she used to do like some
[ __ ] like
gucci book but french and nikki
get a bag too and they come together so
it got to a point when we started going
out because we used to
record a lot in atlanta miami and [ __ ]
like that but now when
carter iii come out wayne on the road
and
he used to tell us [ __ ] like he used to
tell me a lot
this is what made me start coming he was
like yo i don't think it's fair to the
other artist that you get to go home
and then fly back when you want to come
back out like they don't go home
they just they on the road with me but i
had never been a part
of nothing like that to understand an
artist like him that lives on the road
like lives on a tour bus you know what
i'm saying i was more like i when y'all
come to new york or you want me to come
back out let me know
his thing was mills i [ __ ] with you you
need to be here
whenever what you there for what you're
doing there right young money ain't in
new york
we on the road why you there you young
money right and then it hit me like
all right i got to be here more so nicki
at that time she was booked so she got
her own
she's building like her own nikki
lewinsky
you know i'm saying she building her own
little thing beam me up scotty tape
in them clubs like she was getting them
getting bags while we ride on the bus
with wayne
and we you know he bringing us out she's
doing that too but
she might have a bag to get in south
carolina or here
and i think he started to feel like you
know he never wanted nobody to feel like
they was better than another artist like
i don't want nikki to feel like she
better than chanel or
guns just because she booked but i don't
want mills to feel like he bigger than
twist or chucky
just because he'd been on tv with diddy
before and he did battles and he had
deals like
we all at the same level y'all all the
same level phil right now like let's
look don't look down on nobody
because i ain't looking down on you now
if you're gonna look down on little
chucky a little twist or you're gonna
look down on guns
i gotta look down on you now mills i
have to
you know what i'm saying like so once we
got that [ __ ] in our mind
wayne was looking at it i think like
nikki doing her own thing
i think wayne was looking at it on some
[ __ ] like
oh she trying to be over here
and over here and kind of see which one
popped first
you got to remember it wasn't no every
girl in the world yet it wasn't no
we was just wayne's crew you know what
i'm saying but gucci was still gucci
like french wasn't
big big big french montana yet but he
coke boys and he so he don't know if
like nicki was
like you [ __ ] know you over here like
you [ __ ] with us are you [ __ ] with
them you [ __ ]
and i think he just had one of them days
where he was like yo she ain't younger
money no more like
and then she started just working she'll
be at video shoots here and there
change hair color start wearing tight
dresses and did he tell that to her
i don't know if he i don't i don't want
to say he told it to her he probably
told mac
or toltez to call or whatever she never
said nothing she
he never said nothing and then
him being a businessman and just
understanding where he trying to take
young money
i think he told mack ortez like
yo we put in too much work to just let
her go
like tell her i said you know what i'm
saying
and then she was back on the road with
us but she was still doing her own thing
but she was back in a row but i could
understand how he could feel like that
because it's like yo
is you over here or is you over there is
you not like what is you doing right now
you know what i'm saying so they came to
the agreement and after that
everything was cool you know what i'm
saying but i think it was a
misunderstanding it wasn't like it was a
miscommunication somewhere
same thing with the drake [ __ ] i think
wayne and drake thing at that time was
more so wayne and tez you know what i'm
saying like wayne trusting ted's with
[ __ ]
and then finding out like some [ __ ]
might not be what it is
and like but now drake is in the middle
of it
because it's like you know it's that
business that paperwork [ __ ] and like
all of that type of [ __ ]
i think that was an issue you know what
i'm saying i was in the studio with
drake in new york and
cool chilling everything cool smoking
recording
and he went up we went the hallway came
back
and i was like he's like yeah man he's
like tuned just told me i'm not young
money no more
same thing you just did i was like i was
like where the [ __ ] that come from like
because this is at a time where like
every girl is out
like we you know we charting like
drake's doing like uh say something
and digital girl like he's doing like
features now for mary jay and drake i
mean not drake
mary j jamie foxx yeah he doing like
[ __ ] outside of the box and i think it
was that same thing again
it was like that yo what y'all like
cause there's so much [ __ ] going on but
wayne don't know
you know what i'm saying he don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on with his
artists and i think that was the thing
with drake it wasn't it wasn't really
nothing with drake because even drake
told him he was like
he said it really don't have nothing to
do with you
and me just knowing wayne i know he was
having one of them days where it's like
[ __ ] is everybody keeping me in the dark
with [ __ ] if these is this is my [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and just once
again miscommunication
miss seeing the same thing with
[ __ ] what little twist i mean we
don't i mean little twist wasn't in the
bedrock video if you noticed lil chucky
was
all through the bedrock video but he
wasn't on the song
was it is it because wayne wasn't
[ __ ] no matter because got him
trouble in school or some [ __ ] like that
oh wow or tutoring or something
happening with his mom's like
so wayne wouldn't let him be in the
video he just let little chucky be all
through he let little chucky be the
extra in everybody's verse
that's so funny that's so funny you know
what i'm saying
i remember i don't want people to feel
like oh this [ __ ] just want to sit up
there and tell stories while people are
they no i'm
just telling you real [ __ ] and i'm going
to tell you about when my stupid ass got
kicked out
if you remember the bt awards
when drake's foot was hurt he had just
[ __ ] his foot up when he was on tour
he had two as acl
but he still came out and performed at
the bt awards and i think uh
uh rashinay came out on stage it wasn't
meant to be disrespectful but
they was performing every girl i say
they because as i tell this story this
is gonna [ __ ] everybody up
so when they was performing every girl
and drake was sitting in the chair and
the kids came out
they pulled the performance and they
never showed it again because we was
performing i just want to [ __ ] every
girl in the world and
people had their kids up there and we
was just happy that we made it
to the awards show you know what i'm
saying wayne usually perform with the
hot boys cash money
this is like everybody this is like
young money the [ __ ] that he had the
plan he had for us this [ __ ] came to
life
we on stage bt awards jay mills wasn't
on that stage
jay mills was in new york
on 112th and 5th avenue
down the block from the projects looking
at
that performance at his homies crib
vado was there with me shout out to vado
and
the girl that i had pregnant at that
time sitting next to me
about eight months pregnant and i'm
looking at them perform like oh i'm done
i missed my flight two flights
two flights flights from newark airport
had a whole nother flight book from jfk
by the time i got the jfk missed that
one too
we have to perform at the bt awards
first
live tv performance
now my verse was performed
but it wasn't me who performed it shout
out to my brother mac main
because at that time we both had the
same facial hair and we both had like
low caesars and [ __ ]
and we was like husky chubby husky type
dudes
hey he just went on stage with some
shades and he's
i ain't you know that's why i ain't
being disrespectful baby i'm just being
back
damn but luckily for milsie
the [ __ ] performance got pulled so it
never even ended up
happening like it happened no no it
happened but it happened you just can't
find it anywhere yeah i mean you made
somebody may have uploaded to youtube or
some [ __ ] like that but yeah but it
didn't actually make the broadcast
not live and then when they whenever
they showed their awards
after that they just never showed that
performance now
this is all a part of my getting kicked
out of the young money story
so mack like yo we uh we're in new york
but we're about to leave you know we're
about to leave from where the jet lead
from
we're about to go to paris we're about
to go through the paris run
and uh overseas and do all that [ __ ]
so mac was like i don't really want you
to miss this because you know you need
to be here you know too mad he ain't
[ __ ] with you like
you're not young money right now he said
but
you know i just want to see you know
what i'm saying like let's just
you got to face it you know what i'm
saying say you can't just chill because
if you chill he'll never call you again
so i will say if it wasn't for mac main
i would have been curved from young
money a long time
a long time ago so regardless and me and
mac
we didn't had a million disagreements
almost came to fights a million times
mac man is like a big brother to me like
he's like the big brother
that you always get into a fight with
but he kind of always
write years later like the [ __ ] he was
telling you years ago that y'all got an
argument about
[ __ ] kind of he kind of was right but he
kind of didn't word it right and he
always both fiery at that time
so mac was like yo just come to the jet
and let's just see if he wants you to
come to paris with us
so when i get some i get to the jet
they not there yet so i just get on the
jet and i just wait for them to but he's
like we're a few minutes away
so i remember they got on the jet right
so i remember i mean that
i think streets couple people macmain
assistant
everybody get up on the joint and they
look at me and just go
so i'm i'm dabbing everybody but you
know like on the jet
well let's say we're on the jet and you
coming in right here and we got the sofa
right here they got the captain seats
right there you know wayne sit all the
way in the back
all his bags everything you know so i'm
sitting on the sofa
everybody walking by dapping me so wayne
get on the j
he get on the jet right so he get up he
look at me like
he just keep walking like it threw him
off to see me right
so now we waiting jetbot to take off
so everybody talking
a couple people talking to me but i
noticed wayne his his conversation ain't
reaching where i'm at
so he back there he listened to his
music you know looking out the window so
i said all right
this is this ain't this ain't like
friendship this is business right now
you have to
go apologize like you missed a you
missed a performance at the bet awards
you have to go speak to this man i
walked back there
i was like yo you know what i'm saying
my fault for missing the flight you know
what i'm saying i apologize i know that
[ __ ] was unprofessional blah blah blah
blah
and like he looked at me said he said
what'd you say
so i was like nah i'm talking about if i
said no i heard you but i'm asking you
what you say
i said you're right i just went and sat
back down
from teterboro to paris
this man did not say a word to me spoke
to everybody else
joking ha ha food uh
just kept walking by me the whole flight
even when we got to paris checked i had
my
it wasn't like he [ __ ] on me when i
got to paris but
behind closed doors i felt that [ __ ]
like i was definitely on like curve time
for a while and if it wasn't for mac
main like telling me like yo just come
to the jet
and like just see what happened if i
would have been on some [ __ ] [ __ ] and
been like
nah man [ __ ] that [ __ ] if he ain't
[ __ ] with me he ain't [ __ ] with me
like
you know what i'm saying like i had to
eat that [ __ ] but i was wrong
you know what i'm saying so that's my
story of
when i got [ __ ] curved you know what
i'm saying i definitely thought it was
over for me though now you're in the
you're independent now what when wha
what what year did you like officially
have like an official
split away from young money i know it
was cordial yeah i left young money the
end of 2016
and i'm gonna tell you why i left uh
into 2016 i had my surgery already and i
had a surgery in 2015 to remove a tumor
out my throat
my daughter was born in 2012. so 2016
she going on five
i'm not the same dude i was in 2007.
you know i'm not the same 20 son year
old kid running around wanting to [ __ ]
every girl in the world at this point
like i got a little girl in this world
now like just the way i think now is
different
and then it's like now it's bad with
wayne and birdman now
you know what i'm saying oh yeah yeah
that was like yeah yeah it was bad
and i'm one of them and i was always
good with birdman and wayne
you know what i'm saying so we was all
kind of caught in the middle of this
[ __ ] now
but now it's like i'm one of them i'm a
rider to the wheels fall off dude
at that point and i feel like to some
people mills you should have been left
i remember busta rhymes seeing me in a
sneaker store in miami and being like yo
what are you doing what you waiting for
like you waiting for them to stop
[ __ ] with you like
to make you feel that or you you're
going to like just see it you know what
i'm saying but at that time
i'm like nah he gave me a chance i owe
him a little bit more
to leave because it's not good right
he's not going you know what i'm saying
because it's not good right now i owe
him a little bit
more than to leave right now i gotta i
gotta ride this one out you know what
i'm saying
even if my loyalty is turning into
stupidity
i owe him this to ride this out with him
you know what i'm saying
now when he got to a point where
i just didn't know what i was doing no
more right you know what i'm saying i
didn't know when i come around
if i was supposed to be there not you
know what i'm saying i don't know if
like
i'm overstaying and this is just real
[ __ ] cuz i never really said this to a
lot of people in young money i never
said this to
wayne you know what i'm saying like real
[ __ ] i never said this to
birdman or mac main or nothing like that
but
i just felt like i was overstaying my
welcome and i felt like the southern
hospitality
wasn't gonna let them [ __ ] on me
you know what i'm saying that they they
got good hearts they're not [ __ ] up
individuals i'm never going to say that
you know what i'm saying
but i think that southern hospitality of
you know i'm saying i [ __ ] with him but
i just don't know what to do with him
you know what i'm saying i think that
was just like
he a good you know milsie family
you know what i'm saying so it got to i
could either be family
and just you know
you don't know what they trying to do
with you and they don't really know what
they're trying to do with you
and just to be real with you they don't
have an
idea of doing anything with you at this
point
like this is the rebuild of little wayne
at this time
no because i remember during that period
of time
when he was beefing heavy with birdman
wayne went on this like club run
in the south where he was taking bags
that like you would never have
ever expected wayne to take like he did
a show in tampa when i was living in
i think that was around the time i was
like i just had was 2015 you said
like 2015. i was around that time i had
my surgery and
i think i was healing yeah like he did
he did a show in tampa for like 40 bands
at a nightclub
and i remember being like wait
little wayne doing something for forty
thousand dollars
like but i think it was because he was
just i think i i i obviously
speculation but i just think he was just
grabbing cash yeah because i mean all
the cash
at the end of the day he was doing the
whole thing but he was doing this whole
club run that like
you would never think wayne would do
yeah yeah and i was
you know what it was for me mostly it
was
i could even stay here cause you gotta
remember i got a kid now so i could even
stay here
and figure out what he going to do
or i could go figure out what i'm going
to do
because it's not like you're on a young
money salary no
it wasn't like it was i'm assuming by
like then it was not any income coming
in it wasn't like it was beef no it was
still income coming in because we don't
we've been on hit records we've been on
albums
i mean i'm obviously getting it but i
mean like as far as
new money the plan like because at this
time i'm looking at it like i
i'm looking at like drake on four fifth
nicky
i'm looking at it like i now i'm looking
at the what's the plan
like what is the plan for me not what is
the plan
for wayne you know what i'm saying this
is like the first time when now i really
have to look at like
bro nobody's gonna take you on tour
nobody's gonna throw you on a single
nobody's gonna jump on your single
nobody's gonna
promote your single nobody's gonna
promote any [ __ ] thing you have going
because
everybody has their own [ __ ] going
right and [ __ ] is so different now when
i came around people were still selling
ringtones
by the time i left young money music was
coming out on fridays now
right it's no longer tuesdays yeah it's
no longer people lining up in front of
the stores all the stores closed
all the websites we used to send our
music to [ __ ] is cornballs now
yeah you could just put it on streaming
platform why are we not putting our
music on streaming platforms why is
wayne
not putting projects on stream why
doesn't wayne have a four-pack out why
doesn't wayne
have an ep out why don't we just put out
the new young money mixtape to promote
everybody who's sitting here ice [ __ ]
cold
and at that time when i got to think
about all that i'm a virgo i get lost in
my own mind it's like yo
psych yourself out like it's like yo you
gotta go
yeah you gotta go not a bad thing like
man [ __ ] these [ __ ] they ain't do
nothing for me nah whoa whoa
young money did more for jay mills than
any other label
did for jay mills even if y'all did put
me on a promo run
and pay for the no no no video put me
here
put me there i don't have no plaques i
don't have no plaques from anything
before young money
right i don't have big ass cap checks
from anything before young money so i
could never say
man [ __ ] them [ __ ] held me up right
no you got lost in the midst of some
great [ __ ]
it happens like that sometimes now what
you're going to do now keep it moving
learn how to produce learn how to direct
shoot your own videos
i had to figure it i had to basically
figure it out
the same way i had to figure it out when
i got with young money i was no deal i'm
taking
shots in the dark i could listen and see
when i hit the rim i'm close
keep taking them [ __ ] shots what'd
you tell me the other day it's the
perfect time for somebody like
you yeah i told you yo i'm gonna give
you a record blah blah blah and what did
you tell me
can i say what you told me about the
radio record yeah sure [ __ ]
the radio right now mills facts facts
bro
and i work at the radio and i told when
i left because i had my lady with me
and when i left we was talking about
that [ __ ] and i was like
i needed to hear that yeah dawg ain't
the same out here
you hear it because once again like when
we were talking about see
i'm only reiterating this because they
wasn't here for the conversation over
there
like i was explaining to you that i'm
from an era of
the single i'm from an era of the radio
record or the
the party record i moved in miami 2010
that's prime strip club for sure
i was there for live on sunday king of
diamonds monday i know what that [ __ ] is
like
to be with somebody very very underrated
tootsies
i am super cheap let's just get that
understood i have never went to king of
diamonds and got singles
used to go every monday likewise see i
like to go to the strip club and eat
food
what the [ __ ] am i getting money for
wayne just got a box of ones
right right a box and went here
here here
what the [ __ ] am i going to get singles
for so you think you think i'm
impressing him
going to get this rack of singles hell
this [ __ ] just went up sold a million
in the first week what are you talking
about
yeah i'ma get out of his box but that's
the type of person he is
right so like i used to always tell
people when
i got around young money that [ __ ] me
up to be like when we on the road and
he pulling the red lobster we on an 18
hour bus ride he pulled in the red
lobster
i tell this story a lot cause i'll be
trying to paint a picture for people
right
pulling the red lobster he gets steak
shrimp baked potato
it's 21 orders of steak shrimp and baked
potatoes
oh i'm not paying for that who paid for
that
you got are you chipping in for that mac
who paying for this mac
mills just order
[ __ ] went like that for a long time no
it went like that forever it never
stopped right
so when it got to a point where like you
were saying i'm looking at him he's
taking a 40
foul bag hill a 50 thou bag here
it's like i know why
you know what i'm saying because that
[ __ ] is on his shoulders and that's all
he know
since he was 13 all he know is that all
he know is
that lifestyle chauffeur his overhead
had to be crazy
that's all he know right you know what
i'm saying i always tell people if i was
if i was if i was little wayne like if i
had little wayne money
like i would have been way worse i would
have been
worse way worse but he had money since
he was so young
so he understood how to take care of his
homies how to try to
put jay mills and cory guns and even if
it don't work he understood how to try
right right right so i could i could
accept that you know what i'm saying but
i don't know man i feel like like i said
the [ __ ] ended how it was supposed to
end
for me as far as that chapter now of
course i still [ __ ] with wayne i still
[ __ ] with everybody else
but do i think i could have gotten more
out of young money
had i stayed no do you think you should
have left earlier
yeah yeah i probably should have left
young money years before i left
but once again man it is what it is
wayne gave me an opportunity
that nobody else has ever given me
before or since
so i don't feel i did anything wrong you
know what i'm saying i feel like i could
have left
but i remember people used to tell me
man you should go to maybach
oh mmg you should go to you should go
here you should go here and if you think
about it wayne was the
only place i ever went other than having
my own deals
yeah i think that like signing with an
artist is a crap shoot
anyway you know when you signed with
another artist i think wayne pulled it
off nicely with nikki and drake i think
ross
did a great job but like there's plenty
more examples
of rappers who have labels yo gotti's
doing a great job right now
yeah um but there's plenty of other
artists who it's like you just look and
it's like
the problem is most of the time when you
sign with an artist they don't want
the people they sign to be bigger than
them yeah and
that's you know with wayne that didn't
happen with ross that that wasn't the
case
yeah some people been around so long
it's not the first time
like when ross did the whole maybach
music [ __ ] he had already did triple c's
right yeah he had already seen the car
already did write in for slipping like
he had already did so much [ __ ]
so it wasn't his first time yeah yeah
yeah shout out to ross
yeah the mmg energy in like 2000 and
like
10 11 was so crazy
and i feel like young money i'ma say
this
i don't feel young money gets enough
credit for bringing back that aura
that crew the crew like after like dip
set
and g-unit that was it that was the that
was the end of
that era of like d-block g-unit
dip said uh rough riders rockefeller
you know it's like all of those like
crews and then like young money came
and i remember we used to get joked on
it was the joke you know we had the
poppy singles and [ __ ] like that but we
still had like dedication three
dedication four like no ceilings like
awesome i think
i think the reason why we we was like
like i am music tour was like
six months man it was like the biggest
tour but at that time
that's when top was creating
uh tde like i met j-rock through wayne
yeah
the song that was j-rock's first single
on warner brothers wayne directed the
video i remember when we flew
out here i remember that was when
kendrick was being at that video shoot
like yeah i think i'm just gonna stay in
the trailer
right like you gotta understand i'm from
harlem
wayne out here with dickies and red
bandannas and [ __ ] i'm like
i'm new i don't even know wayne for
being like this yet
you know what i'm saying i'm like [ __ ]
is nickerson but i'm learning
you know what i'm saying i'm just like
oh he's like yeah i'm directing this
video
for my uh for my men's artist i'm like
who
said my man j-rock i didn't know who tde
was i didn't know none of that
but i remember like after young money
they was the first people i remember
being like
oh they building some [ __ ] like what we
doing not the same thing of course not
but i remember because schoolboy q was a
part of ged
with ty that was tiger's crew yeah i
don't want to say tiger's crew that was
all crew you know
i remember shout out to shout out to q i
remember i remember q
from being around tiger like so i
already knew he was
nice you know what i'm saying i already
knew j-rock
from wayne uh doing the video
i had heard of ab soul
uh a lot of us knew like found out about
kendrick
what was this section of section 80
section 80.
but he was on one he was on drake [ __ ]
he was on like an interlude or something
am i bugging was kendrick on like a
drake was he on a cart of carter
four in the room nah kendrick was on
like because i remember we asked him we
was like yo who that
i don't remember he broke down the verse
about how kendrick was talking about how
they met and he went here and
he was like that's exactly how it
happened was it a drake album
i think that was i had to eventually yo
if if i'm bugging right now how do you
apologize
it had to be carter four carter four had
all those interludes with like bun b
was it called was it a drake album
oh wait you're right you're right you're
right he was on a um yeah on a drake
album it was on
kendrick it was on take care all right
so now
i'm peeping i'm like but at this time
ross is doing
get married alive there you go cause i
remember asking drake like
you know and he broke in he was like yo
he's nice and he was rapping the verse
like he said and that's exactly
how it happened like how we you know
yeah kendrick was already like on his
way though so
pde maybach music they took that whole
[ __ ]
and ran with it that kind of like
birthed
the whole and then after that like cole
look with dreamville
you know what i'm saying like he built
that [ __ ] quick
it wasn't quick but now if you if you
look at it if you look at if you look at
the freshman cup and i got a lot i got
in all sorts of trouble for saying
my [ __ ] man was supposed to be on the
cover i worried i remember when i said
the
double xl cover was wack because vado
wasn't on it
oh i caught so much flack for that cause
everybody thought i meant
every person on the cover was whack
because that was the j
cole freight gig and that was and that
was one of the best [ __ ] covers
it turned out to be one of the best
covers i was just mad my homie wasn't on
there i felt he deserved to be on there
cool
worded it wrong but if you look at from
that time
on cole built dreamville kind of fast
well no he had a cause out of everybody
on that cover
him he had he had omen signed a dream
deal for there's a guy named omen that
he had signed to the
like dreamville was a thing for a while
no but i mean like
from what the public first saw because
young money was a thing
for a while young money been in bennett
thinks
does jr smith have a young money tattoo
on his throat
young money is he i was just watching
homie
okay okay i didn't know yeah i'm like yo
why does this nba player have a gigantic
young money tattoo on his [ __ ] throat
the henny guy i remember was at the
bedrock video shoot and i noticed i was
like oh she got a stupid big young money
tattoo on his neck
jesus christ yeah they homies they're
cool he's got to regret that tattoo
you know what i don't really think j.r
smith regrets too much
that might be fair i don't think anybody
who can drink honey on game night i
don't think they regret too much man
shout out to jr man
yeah so look your album is out and
is this like the beginning of you
putting out a [ __ ] kind of like what's
your like what are your plans
now earlier earlier this year i put out
pole music five last year i put out
feels like i was here before
keywords my thing right now is
just figure out where you fit in right
now there's so much [ __ ] going on like i
love the
drill [ __ ] of course i love the lyrical
[ __ ] i love the melodic [ __ ]
i love the auto-tune [ __ ] i really wish
i could
fit in all of those lanes but i've tried
it
and i don't just rap you know what i'm
saying like i i learned
i learned i say this [ __ ] a whole lot
you could probably find a million
interviews when i say this
just because you can do something
doesn't mean you should there you go man
come on man just because you can do
something does not mean you should
you know what i'm saying like
i could go out and i could [ __ ] ten
strippers in the strip club
that doesn't mean you should there you
go
whether you got a girl at home or not
well if you don't have a girl at home
no you st it's still it's coveted it's
cold oh yeah you shouldn't [ __ ] you
shouldn't
have sex with 10 different people at all
right now
i mean i mean i don't speak in pandemic
times i concur but you know just
you know what i'm saying it's like i can
dj
you know i can get on the wheels of
still and right
should i i mean i should probably a lot
of other rappers have
i should probably not you can probably
you can probably tell him to load a beat
up
right now uh talk your [ __ ] i'm not
rapping
[ __ ] see now you could
should you of course not like should you
really do that
i don't know if you should know so
that's where i'm at with it man i'm just
trying to see where i fit in
i'm having fun with this [ __ ] i'm
independent with empire
i love my splits y'all in trouble when i
hit it hit the liquid one
and i think that that's what that's the
beauty of this era
and that's probably what made me leave
young money too just realizing i ain't
need a machine in this era no more you
don't man
you know what i'm saying that cuts off
the middle man it's not the right
consumer
it's like it's not to say it like that
but i come from an era of
the machine i was part of warner
brothers machine i was part of universal
machine and
steve rifkin over at src and my part of
young money's
you were signing src no i didn't know
actually i was signed to universal and
then
when they started doing a bunch of
shifting and [ __ ] like that like
me and my team we didn't really like the
david banner akon era
of src yeah david benner was up there
i've been being on the road with david
benner i'm gonna be on the road with
remy
oh yeah remy was on that starting up
there with akon steve rifkin oh man
shout out to steve rivkins he's managing
busta rhymes now
yeah he's busted his manager now that's
dope man and shout out to buster too
i seen an interview with buster was
talking about the surgery
uh surgery he had and i actually [ __ ]
me up cause that's the same surgery i
had
and i never really heard nobody like
talk about that [ __ ] [ __ ] like
it scared me from the perspective of
uh you know when some [ __ ] happened to
you you don't feel it
no that's a bad analogy you have a
you have a uh you smoke weed yeah you
ever smoke a bunch of weed and then walk
in the mall
and wonder why everybody looking at you
think maybe it's sneaky you know you got
the new sneaker you got some new yeezys
on it you don't have a similar uh
and you don't realize you smell like the
back of the dispensary like it all just
came in and you opened it and rubbed it
all over your skin but you're high
so you don't you're cool you don't smell
that [ __ ] that's meat or i don't
i smell amazing i still smell like the
cologne i sprayed this morning
you smoked eight blunts since then mills
you don't smell like that
but i'm in it so i don't see it i
remember the first time i seen wayne
have a seizure on the jet
in the air now i have seizures i have
seizures in my sleep
oh wow like scariest [ __ ] ever so
but every time i've had a siege in my
sleep i wake up and i'm cool
like yo you were there when wayne had a
seizure
like two different times scariest [ __ ]
i've ever seen in my life
i it cause it made me feel you know
it made me feel like oh that's what i
look like
and then when he got
that conclusion i don't i don't know if
it's i don't i can't really say it
because once again
i own sibling and i have a history of
you never sipped lean
around all the meat i tried it one time
but i tried it by my
[ __ ] was quadruple cupping i
tried it by mistake i mean gutter gutter
was in hit factory one time and uh i had
a sun kiss
and you know you got the white cups with
the ice right i poured it in there
but i didn't realize that uh he had some
lean and some sun kissed too you know
what i'm saying somewhere so when i hit
the cup
i'm like oh this [ __ ] tastes sweet you
know tastes good actually you know what
i'm saying
but i'm like i'm thinking maybe you know
it's just a good ass sun kiss right now
i caught one
hit it again i remember like oh i was
just like
slumped beat playing like i'm trying to
get up
i feel good though but i'm just wow
comfortable like and he's like no [ __ ]
you drunk my cup [ __ ]
i'm like nah that was my cup like my
meals your cup over there [ __ ] that's
my cup right here i'm like oh
[ __ ] and that's when i realized the
whole time i was drinking got a gutter
cup
did everyone like was it like a panic
when
when like he had a seizure because
that's an alarming thing to witness
especially wayne yeah
yeah that [ __ ] is a panic but it was a
panic for me because everybody looking
at me like
mills you do it's like yo i've never
i'm i'm i usually be in the mode he's in
right
now and i remember when he woke up he's
like yo i'm good everybody you know
and they had the ems on the thing let me
get the [ __ ] off my jet
because we had to land the jet we was
going to l.a we had to land the jet
for the ems to get on and now we got to
put the jet back up in the air
so rich [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not i don't live
on rich [ __ ] [ __ ]
even with money i want to live on broke
[ __ ] [ __ ] you live like you broke
you'll stay rich
right man put this [ __ ] back up in the
[ __ ] air y'all know how much
this [ __ ] gas costs
i was like that guy has a point right
now we did land his jet
now we have to put it back up in the air
and land it again it's a whole nother
fee
that none of us have paid he had a
seizure though now granted
i'm i'm like i get it i get where he's
coming from
oh y'all get the [ __ ] off my jack come
on i got i got to get to la because he
got to get that later
do a event like a video game event or
something like that now you know you
don't do that
now you had to pay for the gas to put
the jet back up again
and you got to give them back that
deposit they gave you because you only
show up to that event you lost twice
today
um jet go back up in the air he like
milsie
he like that she was that bad it was it
was serious like that
and i promise you i i did not want to
you know you don't want to really say
that but i'm like
[ __ ] was bad bro that was the first time
i probably told him something he didn't
want to hear it's like bro that [ __ ] was
the scariest [ __ ] i've ever seen in my
life
like like i don't want to see you like
that ever again my [ __ ]
he's like word he's like believe that
blood love you know what i'm saying
yeah and then after that when we land he
went to
he went to the hospital and that's when
he stayed overnight and you know
but that [ __ ] was scary man because it's
like and that's why i said i don't want
to
i don't want to put it to the lean i
don't you know what i'm saying because
when i
have seizures it's from overworking
myself it's
high blood pressure and low sugar count
it's it's an imbalance
you know what i'm saying so it ain't it
ain't perks and zannies and
lean cause i got a history of this [ __ ]
and i don't do none of that [ __ ] right
you know what i'm saying like the
closest to a pill i'm going to get his
partying with an e pill or molly back in
the day it's just it does seem like that
that is so
different people bodies you know they it
should hit different but
that that's some scary [ __ ] damn was
that like something where like you think
that like it maybe changed the way he
thought about
some of the recreational use of stuff he
had going on probably
probably when you almost die your life
flash before you you think about all
sorts of [ __ ]
that's real that's whether you get shot
you get stabbed you get jumped
natural causes i remember when the
doctor told me i got
you know i got six months if i don't get
this surgery
and then he said i'm gonna let you be
with your lady in six months
and walked out like damn i'm gonna let
you figure out if you want to get this
surgery or do you want to wait it out a
little bit
right and at that time it's april my
daughter
three years old you telling me i'm not
making it
to and then when you go through all that
it's like no i gotta
put everything back in perspective and i
promised myself since 2015
i wouldn't deprive my fans i wouldn't
cheat myself i wouldn't waste my time
overthinking [ __ ] or holding the music
hostage
yo we're uh breaking down this video
we're not breaking it down we're taking
a break in the video
to tell you all about our sponsors odd
socks all right listen man
uh oddssocksofficial.com what the [ __ ]
was that bro
uh it was like a [ __ ] pomeranian hair
floating in the air
anyway odd socksofficial.com keyword
bootleg kev
go over there get you some socks and
you'll save 20 off if you use that
keyword they got south park
license they got some ghostbusters pimp
c
mike tyson really the one that i really
care about is they got that wwe license
you can get these awesome nwo socks
and then they got their odd socks basics
you know for all the basic [ __ ] get
you some basic socks
even though they are very comfortable um
they're probably the most comfortable
socks
actually not probably definitively the
most comfortable socks i've ever put on
my feet
yes all right and that goes for all
types of socks
so go to oddssocksofficial.com get some
socks by the way
spongebob socks the kind of fly right
christmas time is on the way
use the keyword bootleg kev 20 off odd
socks official dot com
support us by supporting odd socks let's
go
you know what i'm saying a lot of times
as artists we hold music hostage because
we plan so much you you're overthinking
you're thinking like
yo i need i need somebody to push this
and push that [ __ ] yourself you got
instagram you got twitter you got
stories you got timelines
be annoying be annoying be like the
[ __ ] that
be like hey follow my hot bestie and
never met them [ __ ] before
be like that there's a lot of those i
know it sounds crazy
fellas but the moment you swallow that
pride and you stop thinking like it's
08 or 2013 this [ __ ] is different man
people out here making all sorts of
money that don't have no hot music
now i'm not saying you need to put out
[ __ ] music but
this is the era of don't work harder
work smarter man
facts facts like i'm the king of working
hard we're both i'm the king of
working super super hard but somewhere
not connecting the dots because you're
so busy working hard
you're so busy busting your ass working
hard you ain't connecting the dots with
the work
right you know what i'm saying and
that's where that's where
i'm at with it i don't know where a lot
of other artists is at with it but i
feel like
everything is different now man we was
talking about tiger over there and i was
telling you
i remember when tiger came out with
album singing a few years ago everybody
was laughing at him [ __ ] horrible
everybody was laughing at him yeah no
time that [ __ ] said
he never looked back yeah now tiger had
a rough patch man
we all do so i got a rough time i mean
like the thing is he just kept throwing
up shots
and then the [ __ ] the taste was i'm
gonna say some real [ __ ] man i've been
in this game
a long time i know people may not
realize it they may not look at it like
that
because i came into this [ __ ] young and
adam did battle solo [ __ ] young money
[ __ ] independent [ __ ]
ups downs all that i've been in this
[ __ ] two decades
when you in this game as long as
somebody like me or you got longevity in
this [ __ ] and you learn how to stay
afloat
you're going to have some patches where
[ __ ] get dropped of course of course
every one of my favorite
artists had a dry patch nas is one of my
favorite artists
nostradamus album exists there was
project project windows was solid jay-z
is one of my favorite
artists the kingdom come album exists
i would i would argue kingdom comes his
second worst it exists
you know what i'm saying like it however
you want to look at it
same way you said uh cardiff it was cool
it wasn't cool that might be your that
might be your it exists
there's a listen if i don't want to die
what i'm saying i i tried
i'm not diving down little wayne's had a
rough decade yeah it's a
but you gotta think quality wise harder
three and then no ceilings and then
after no ceiling [ __ ] just went left for
me as a fan i was like all right
yeah but you you got to take the good
with the bag because if you're going to
take those four or five then you got to
take the 15 before that that was a
monumental
and now we gotta wait we got a way to
drought and dedication one and
dedication
yeah i mean we got a way to carter one
to two to three i just think back to
like
that i am not a human hundred degrees
what was the rock star album we was
doing rock music
it had dropped i remember that i
remember uh it dropped the world with
eminem
which was a solid solid song but i hit
number one
the album probably did little wayne
could literally [ __ ] but that's what i
mean 70 minutes
did we listen to the snoop lion album
did we listen to the snoop lion album
of course not all right number one
everything's not for everybody no way
the snoop dogg album was number one on
the gospel album hit number one
no way
okay wait wait wait what chart are we
talking about here
because we're not talking about the
overall billboard all i'm telling you is
i'll give you ten thousand dollars right
now
if snoop dogg's had a number one overall
album in the last seven years
on billboard you don't think so now you
know the gospel chart
yes because there's like two two gospels
oh we're moving the goal post now come
on
no you just move the goal post i'm
telling you we everything's not for
everybody
he might have been number one on the
reggae chart
that's number one no but not number one
like number one
number one that's like saying i got a
number one death metal song out right
now
like it's like yeah but like it's number
one it's number one to somebody in a
genre
no you know what you just said it's
number one to somebody it may not be
number one to you hey shout out to wayne
man shout out to snoop too man
shout out to shout out to snoop but the
the we're not slandering them what we're
basically saying is
when you have longevity like a wayne or
a snoop
you're going to have some dry patches
were you disappointed in the carter five
it was cool it wasn't it wasn't the
avocados
it wasn't like carter two it wasn't like
carter three it wasn't like carter four
i actually think it was better than
carter four but that's not saying much
because i i thought carter foreign but
that's you i think carter four was
better than carter five
so because you were around like the
carter five [ __ ]
uh i know a lot of those songs were
older obviously but like
how many i didn't think i was around for
cardiff i don't think no you weren't
around when it came out but i mean like
the crew they had to be like correct
it changed so much that's what i mean
because there was the changes
it was supposed to come out for so long
and then he was getting held against his
will by
baby it was the freeway oh the free
weezy i remember that he put that [ __ ]
out of the title
easy yeah man well shout out to it
shout out to my man too man he worked
through it he worked through it man
like that's that's one thing i will say
about wayne
he ain't never lay down you know what
i'm saying it's a lot of rappers
that was out when he was out they don't
they laid down
you know what i'm saying they they threw
the towel and they was like [ __ ] it you
know what i'm saying
he rapped through it even if it was some
[ __ ] that you didn't want to hear
that's fair he rapped through it you
know what i'm saying so everybody gonna
have
they dry spots but i'll be feeling like
i'm more for the comeback story
i'm more for like damn how did you
bounce back off that [ __ ] come on man
they counted drake out
everybody was oh [ __ ] you had a son you
[ __ ] dead
it's because drake lost the battle i
didn't everybody they counted
they counted
juice all over this is true and it
changed i remember seeing it with my own
eyes like
and everything changed i remember people
really trying to say like drake was done
i don't know about that no no no no no
drake got fried up by
pushing me though i was literally but
it's drake i was like i was living out
here none of drake's fans know who pusha
t
i was living out here they thought
aubry was done in the terms of that
battle he
was done they thought drake was
done they thought he was done for and
that was the only time he had any sort
of stench well not at the only time
shout out to uh quentin what's good yeah
that that quinton miller
i that that was funny when he said uh
damn [ __ ] got points for saying i had a
son
listen man all i know you got points for
saying who my girl was
drake definitively and
you know what happened after that he
took the l and then god's plan came
of course that's not a l no no in that
specific battle now look i'm not sure
because i don't want to [ __ ] on pusha t
because i'm i'm not i'm i'm not i don't
have anything to do with that anymore no
but push and
push a put put through that out if i and
drake never even replied
i could take if i could take that if i
could take that one if that's the last
high point
that we have for pusha t oh come on
daytona came out after that
i said it's a classic album but you're
not talking to me about a classic album
right now you're talking to me about
a verse over jay-z beat
which was a little light something and
it was so light
and then i'm telling you and then god's
plan came out and then we forgot about
anything that had to do with pusha t now
i'm saying as far as drake go
because i can't do this because cause i
got to keep this a buck right now i
can't [ __ ] on pusha t like pusha t
career don't take my career and like put
his foot on it
and like move it around a little bit
like that you know i'm saying i'm a
realist
but i'm also gonna be a realist and tell
you
after that high point for pusha t
i don't remember look and somebody might
be like mills i don't remember a high
point from you ever shut up
i guess technically came out we just we
but look but look look because i love
drake man i love drake
anything with young money involved i'm
taking the young money side i don't give
a [ __ ]
but he lost would be drake did he lost
he ordered a microphone
with pusha t's uh autograph on it
back in the days yeah cause i remember
when i seen that
and i was like you might you might that
was like a bad one but then you know but
then that turns out that turns into like
the super seniors still borrowing the
freshman it's like bro go to college
yeah pushes that guy bro now push it
look listen
pusha t is undeniably it's probably not
impossible for drake to like
lose in the grand scheme of things
because he's the biggest ever you look
people
you can [ __ ] no you can't lose
you can lose because people you you have
people that will say
nah drake lost that battle then you have
people that say you won the battle
you got people who's saying he won the
battle you will literally have people
that
they're like 12 year old white kids who
don't know what what what
see what you know what you're saying
right now you move in the goal post the
goal
post is who cares how old they are there
are people that will say ether was whack
because they are jay z stands first of
all i'm a naz stan
i'm a non-stand too and you're not my
favorite mcs tell me the beat was wack
but also tell me you know what ether was
before that
yeah yeah okay so listen
in retrospect in retrospect
say it take over was it safe no no but
takeover wasn't
a spec it was there was a noz line in
there
right if we're talking about which song
is better sonically to listen to
i can why does he move the goal no no no
no cause
ether is a better diss record but this
but which song is better to listen to i
didn't ask you which song was better i
said who lost
jay-z and i said there are people like
you who still say but the beast
it's almost like when you watched belly
as a kid and you were like yo this [ __ ]
is fire but then you watch it as a grown
ass man
and you like the last 20 minutes i mean
you're like watching but it's really a
good movie if you've been hustling and
you went out of town and you got money
yeah but you had to drive around and
intrepid and a [ __ ] snitched on you and
then you was getting money and then you
had
you did that before belly's a great
movie it's
i don't know if you did that before i
don't know you keep saying
there's people that say drake drake won
the battle oh y'all
y'all are real y'all really like pusha t
in there i like pushing t too i i love
the album
yeah but you haven't really like what
are you talking about you said oh okay
so who won who won
the battle the overall battle no
we won the battle or the 444 freestyle
and the other [ __ ] like the other [ __ ]
and both of them i like it
freestyle because it had i didn't we
didn't know he had a son
you think drake should have shoulda
replied
i think that would have been good for
rap i think that would have been good
for rap if you'd applied
i think it was a bad look that he didn't
reply and it was a bad look that
that wasn't that similar did meek reply
well no meek didn't need to reply
because
jesus christ his his reply to [ __ ]
back to back was atrocious it was right
he ruined the undertaker's theme song
it was really bad it was over it was
like
okay dude drake just hit you with two of
them bro and then you coming back with
this [ __ ]
but but see on top of that and listen
and i'm not the biggest drake fan in the
world but he undoubtedly beat the [ __ ]
out of meek mill and that it was
it wasn't even a [ __ ] question it was
really sad i remember we were in tampa
and i was just sitting there like man it
might really be over for meek man
cause he this was when he was on twitter
tweeting up a storm
because that's when you know he was like
what he had the trump twitter fingers
and you know what it'd be sometimes too
you know it'd be sometimes too
sometimes you can dig a hole with
uh the fans i know this from battling
like
right you could talk so much [ __ ] that
they want to see you lose like
i think that's what happened with meek
like drake not to say like back to back
but listen meek jumped out though
yeah he was talking crazy you you you
you made it with drake looked like he
was countering
so you made people be like you made
people pick sides you made them be like
now we like him more than you even if
you're right
yeah but you know what i'm saying even
if you're giving us you know what to go
back to
the kanye jay-z [ __ ] even if you're
giving us evidence and you're
right we don't care that's what i've
seen
at that time and i think oh yeah no one
cared they were like what's
going on who cares we don't give a [ __ ]
we still like him more than you and
that's i think that's when it was just
like hold up
he don't write he didn't write that [ __ ]
though so we don't care
i need one dance and we're going to sing
those songs too
hey back-to-back was crazy the fact that
you had to go to a nightclub for
x amount of years and hear the diss song
in every club for two years straight
that [ __ ] was
i'm i'm a fan i'm a fan of all of the
diss record [ __ ] that's why i like this
type of conversation whether it's
pushers drake
no nods won the whole drake or knives or
whole nope
whoever you i don't care if you want to
talk about kim in 50. closest beef ever
though
beanie segal and jada yo how did you
take that
look at here why this [ __ ] took it here
i hurt my spot
ain't nobody put me here closest cause
that was you hear the beanie [ __ ] and
the jada [ __ ] you're like oh
that's what matters see now this
conversation is going somewhere else
that was a time of like
that was like a real time of like [ __ ]
studying like them diss raps
when i'm talking about the crews i was
talking about
d block and dipset g unit state property
i remember that beef that beef went for
a long time that beef went from dj clue
mixtapes to
state property would drive from philly
to new york and go up the funk master
flex and rap for an hour [ __ ]
spj hood die too looking out for nazia
[ __ ] when i find you i'm like whoa
like they're from philly they're at the
radio station on hudson street right now
this is live this isn't like a
pre-recorded thing and then like two
days later
kissing them would come up there or
styles would come out with some [ __ ]
[ __ ] beanie seagull you could suck my
dick with the [ __ ] up on it whoa whoa
what did he just say they got to see
each other at some point you know what
i'm saying so
that's why when i think about like the
new beefs and it's like
somebody might put out a freestyle and
then this one put on like
nah this [ __ ] went from powerhouse to
live performances to [ __ ] throwing
french fries at [ __ ] on that stage
kiss came out on stage in philly see
that's different than
you freestyle over somebody beat and you
put it out and i hear what you're saying
with that being said
that was great replied he he
i waved the white flag and said [ __ ] got
too real guys i got it
i have a reply you know why i think that
would have got bad because i think at
some point drake would have started
saying like which people wives he [ __ ]
and stuff like that
i think it would have gotten bad because
pusha t had like five or six records
just
yo you wanna know what's he's been
waiting for this for like four you want
to know what's crazy
i said that and everybody in the room
face it
because drake [ __ ] everyone's wives no
because that could have got so bad
that could have got so that could have
gotten so bad like
that could have got so bad of the like
oh you think people write for
me i wrote for him hmm
oh for some of the kanye things who
gives a [ __ ] everyone knows con
bret reinfest was jesus rhymefest wrote
jesus
why are you so quick to tell me what
somebody wrote for kanye but she wasn't
quick to tell me what kanye wrote for
jay-z
kanye's my favorite artist ever
listen what i'm saying is kanye's my
favorite artist
but your favorite emcee is nozzle my
favorite overall artist is kanye but
you're not
you're over looking you're overlooking
the same thing that you would put on him
that he's did for other people because
i've never i don't i don't think people
how can we do how can you diss drake
no not you but just i'm just thinking
how could you diss
drake for having a ghost writer if the
person you're assigned to
he writes for that's weird this is all
weird
like we're talking we we talking what
are we talking ganna say you don't even
know what you want to say like creator
he's a gladiator he's a jedi when it
comes to this rap [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
jedi
you don't even know what you want to say
right now i'm saying we moved the goal
post for certain people's
it has nothing to do with this he has
everything to do with this
pusha t has hated drake before he was
ever bro
i'm not even talking about pusha tino
what are we [ __ ] i'm just talking
about
drake and the ghost writing thing
kanye has everything to do i don't care
that drake had a ghost
that people could say wrote for yay or
wrote for this one
i could turn around and say but yay
wrote for
jay-z if we're gonna do that okay so now
we gotta say
jay-z has ghost writers and that's a
whole different conversation
i don't know about it but we don't want
to have that conversation i don't want
to have that call because
i want him to do business with roc
nation and title so i don't want to have
this conversation but i have to keep it
real and tell you that i have
footage and evidence that kanye west
came in the studio gave him a line
and gave him a song a hook and a bridge
i gotta get these devils out of my life
that's kanye i'm from the murder capital
where we murdered
that's kanye lose or for lucifer i did
the beat
that i gave you that i wrote that for
you
that's no different than what quentin
miller did for i don't disagree
but so jay-z don't got ghost writers
play me the kanye reference it's in fade
the black movie you want me to find a
time stamp for you
i know it's in there i remember i have
the movie on dvd i could go you just
don't want it
we don't want to accept that no no [ __ ]
that [ __ ] right like
this is what i would say i think drake
is one of the greatest artists
that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] i don't put
kanye nor drake in the
top mc's like like top ten yeah we could
put them in top artists
exactly now we're talking about like mc
[ __ ] like i can't put them in that
because
because it is very very don't put jersey
in there neither
come on man [ __ ] it on chronic 2001.
what kanye wrote for him on
a couple of lines on a beat that he had
brought to him
no no no no no no no no no he gave him a
bridge a hook
and lines and jay-z went in there and
said it
word for word now i don't want to say i
will give jay-z that pastor
yes i don't want to say kanye wrote for
jay-z
but if we gonna move the goal post for
certain people
we we gotta keep it a buck we gotta we
gotta keep it a buck
jay-z wrote for bugs bunny on the spot
jay-z wrote for dr dre and snoop dogg
i'm aware but we won't say but we won't
say snoop had ghost writers until snoop
came out a couple weeks ago
and said hell yeah he wrote that [ __ ]
for me yeah but again
why we don't why we don't look at it
like that and i love all these people
i'm not [ __ ] on them i'm just trying
to play devil's advocate like
if jay-z could tell me i mean if snoop
could tell me that jay-z wrote still
d-r-e and like hell yeah that [ __ ] was
banging so i said i want to say that let
me i say that [ __ ]
and then i could tell you kanye gave
jay-z some [ __ ]
i said snoop why you overlooked that you
good man you've been in this journalism
[ __ ] too
snoop if we're talking about snoop snoop
also somebody who
openly admits to freestyling at this
point
i got to deal with other people writing
for you and has also openly admitted to
what does that have
to do with jay-z right are we putting
snoop dogg in the top 10 discussion he's
top 20
but i wouldn't put him in the top 10.
top 10 what mc's
who who was doing top anything right now
talking to mc i'm just talking about
in this you know you're talking mc's
we're talking about ghost riders you you
just made a whole different conversation
for us to talk about
now we're talking top 20 so snoop not
top 10 no
top 10 what mc's so
what is snoop if he could freestyle off
the top of his head he's top 20. i think
i think
i think his doggies i think snoop's uh
discography
doggy style dog father who's the biggest
rapper ever
that you you're probably right about i
didn't say he's the best or the greatest
i said he's the biggest rapper ever he
has the biggest debut he got one of the
longest
illustrious careers
he done had his dry patch he had his
drop patch when nobody was [ __ ] with
him and he had to go to new orleans
and he bounced back you know what i'm
saying he did have a dry patch just like
dr dre had a drop patch but i've been
here dog father
what he did was he put out one album i
didn't say they don't i said he had a
dry
patch but his first album was no limit i
said he's that [ __ ] air ball
i said he needed to be he said he had it
but that's the dry patch
but that was that was with new orleans
that was with no limit no he got with no
limit because he was in the studio doing
a verse for mystical for thirty five
hundred dollars
that is a dr did you hear what i just
said snoop dogg got with no limit
you said he was in the studio doing a
feature
with mystical for thirty five hundred
dollars
he said he was [ __ ] up and masterpiece
said you know what i'm gonna give you
thirty five thousand and i'm gonna go
meet with suge knight
he was that was a dry spot before no
limit okay are we talking about
financial dry spots or or quality of
music dry spots because
he didn't have nothing going that's why
he was doing it i mean what we're
talking about
he had doggy style he had a dog father
no i'm telling and then there was no no
i'm telling you what snoop dogg said i'm
not telling you what i
think i'm telling you that he said he
was interested he probably had a
financial
dry spot because suge knight was
probably no i don't have nothing i don't
have no deal
i'm [ __ ] up i need you to come get me
out of my deal this is my dry spot i am
in a deal
with a gang member it's a lot bigger
than me and i can't do [ __ ] that's why
i'm here doing this verse
for 3 500 and i have an album called
doggy style
and i'm here doing a verse for 3 500 for
mystical
that's the dry spot that's that was
before no limit that's a dry spot
but he bounced back he bounced back from
that so that's just
i'm just talking about just quality of
music wise dry spots
yeah you got a dry spot there too oh
definitely every everybody has dry spots
man
that's that's i can't sit up here and
say i can't name
one artist that had a full career
of you you could have said kanye until
[ __ ]
this old jesus king came out and that
just [ __ ] was a [ __ ]
that was atrocious you think jesus king
was the first one
uh i mean personally jesus was was the
one jesus is
change sonics and music i didn't ask you
that i said yes yes i listened to you
i think 808s and heartbreaks change the
sonics and music i think you're a couple
albums late with the yeezus first of all
sir relax i'm just telling you you won't
find a bigger kanye fan in the world
than me
second of all yes i will me kanye
literally has changed it
over and over no yes 808s and
heartbreaks made drake possible
okay so but but jesus did the same thing
for travis for all these people
like the sonics that kanye brought into
hip-hop on jesus was crazy bro
uses that [ __ ] yes you don't think
travis scott was already making that
sound travis scott was working with
kanye on yeezy travis scott was on grand
hustle
no no [ __ ] but no but travis scott was
worked on yeezus with kanye he also was
on grand hustle before he met
kanye i underwent
that was on days before rodeo i know but
that was
we're talking about before what you're
talking about i'm telling you that that
sound was around before kanye he didn't
bring it anywhere somebody bought it
you know what he did
what kanye does is he samples he samples
people's creative
he sampled kid cudi as a human being for
808 and heartbreaks
jay-z sampled all of the philly [ __ ]
flow too definitely oh yeah young
me i was just talking about this i
swiped it
but the problem is is that those guys
were in the stu kid cudi
was there for eight weights and
heartbreak right now travis scott was
there for years
and i swiped that and i took it to a
bigger level exactly i didn't create it
i didn't say he created that
i'm not into the i don't like i swiped
it
it was hot and i swiped it see but the
broad's in atlanta it was hot
and different i'm not that i'm not that
i'm a creator
was heavily influenced by cuddy on 808s
and heartbreaks but cutty was a part of
that [ __ ] album
he was heavily influenced by cut he was
in the [ __ ] studio
he was heave all right it was heavily
influenced by travis
i might get my song like day and night
from kanye until kid cudi was with kanye
we never heard and i can't stop winning
i can't stop we never heard that
type of vibe from kanye until so we
can't say
he did that we all know that was good
that was a cutty thing what do you mean
he did it
all yes it was a cuddy thing that kanye
did
and did it ten times bigger scott no no
no
so you're not you're telling me yes
you're telling me kid cudi
it's not travis west you're it's travis
scott for kid
cuddy it's okay so they're they're his
kids
they're his kids no no cuddy's one of
the most influential artists ever and
kanye is too i'm not taking that away
from him but you got to get credit
you think kid cudi puts out a kid named
cuddy mixtape which was my [ __ ] which
was like his first tape that everyone
jumped on
and if it don't if connie don't get
behind cuddy's like he's going somewhere
else
no no what i'm saying is kanye executed
he brought them dudes in the studio and
they bought the sound they bought that
and you met out the park no you swiped
because your sound is j
dilla backpack yes sound i got broads in
atlanta yeah but see that's not even
true because if you listen to graduation
he was sampling daft punk and [ __ ] like
every single kanye album sonically grows
and is different if you go to college
dropout you can say that jay dilla [ __ ]
right you're right you go to late
registration it's different people that
come around him
is the sound that's that's what i said
and once again i don't want anybody
think i just like having conversation
about music
this is just regular conversation
kanye album i'm a fan of yay i have
every single kanye album i'm saying like
every album is different sonically
they're all different kanye
way before a lot of this [ __ ] like he's
giving me beats cds so i
i'm a kanye west [ __ ] fanatic we sat
up here last week and i told you
[ __ ] like yay cole crit russ
i'm fanatics of them that's what that's
where i'm at with it with that being
said
i this all went back to you saying do i
think jesus was that [ __ ]
up 100 front to back zero skips
that [ __ ] is a classic no i didn't know
bound was on that album
i remember the video for bound came i
said what you did you didn't make it all
the way to the end of the album huh
no i'm not even going live come on man
and i'm a yeezy fan
i'm a blood on the leaves blood on the
leaves
all of that [ __ ] is cool this [ __ ] hold
my liquor this [ __ ]
come on with chief keef dog come on that
[ __ ] is crazy
come on bro black skinhead is crazy
you're tripping ah bro that [ __ ] not
graduation that should not lead to
registration
and heartbreak it's definitely better
than that for pablo that [ __ ] ain't none
of them albums better than life for
pablo whoa
jesus no more no more parties no
jesus is 30 hours come on bro yo you
willing right now man no i love it i
love you we kanye fanatic we go about
this forever
if you're going to say i love you like
look at that camera and
tell the world that jesus is better than
life of power jesus is definitively
better than the life of
can somebody raise their hand in this
room there's four people in here can
somebody
what are we doing right now life of
pablo jesus
if you want to go with life of pablo put
your hand up with me if you're gonna go
with jesus with him and be his friend
i'll take it i'll take it
listen bro god bless uh god bless the
life of pablo great album but jesus was
dog jesus is like it's aged so don't
don't don't don't say it i loved it when
it first came out
you i bought that [ __ ] the same day was
that [ __ ] came out the same day as born
center from jay cole and mac miller
i brought i bought three albums that day
watching movies with the sound dogs
was better than jesus you're [ __ ]
crazy you're [ __ ] crazy
jesus is a [ __ ] classic born sinner
was a good album
jesus might be one of kanye's worst
albums with jesus as king
you're something [ __ ] crazy jesus
is not better than graduation graduation
might be his actually think it's
you're crazy do you think graduation
graduation to me is i put jesus above
graduation no no no you're right that's
that it's
that's kind of like a time to tell you
why i think graduation was like one of
the best
that was the evolution that's like i
take care is like drake's evolution
like my junior and senior only get me
like that speaking [ __ ] into existence i
feel like
like can't tell me nothing and good life
and i wonder and all of that [ __ ] like
barry bonds
everything i'm not made me everything i
am all of that [ __ ] was a moment of
like i beat 50 i sold more than him the
teddy bear beat the bully
that [ __ ] was like a moment in time bro
can't tell me nothing was like
we always wearing scarf like the big
[ __ ] palestinian scarves around our
neck we're going to skinny jeans and
tops i loved graduation we all was doing
that that wasn't
jesus is better than graduation i just
named about eight songs that was
incredible jesus had 10 records go
but what are we talking about here i
just named eight bangers off for
graduation i didn't even get to the end
drunken hot girls is on [ __ ]
graduation that song was yo
can't tell me enough barry bonds with
little wayne is on there yo
barry bonds with lil wayne just has not
aged well go listen to that song today
and tell me that song's aged well we out
of here baby
big brother was great big brother was on
there too everything i'm not made me
everything i am that album's not better
than late registration
i'm still naming songs you stopped at
one what are we talking blood on the
leaves black skin head
don't drop my liquor keep going that's
three keep going
welcome to the good life can't tell me
nothing i wonder bro
was flashing lights on there cause we
could stop talking right now flashing
lights was on late registration
late registration to me no no no you're
cheating what do you mean you're
cheating right now
how flashing lights was on graduation
that was the i wonder
was it i wonder if and then flashing
like yes you lost
oh yeah you're right it was a better
album than jesus it's not better than
late registration
it's better than jesus you lost i mean
that's a that's see that
registration is incredible too like you
don't argue with that
my beautiful twist like all of these
albums are better
than the 10 song yeezus album all of
them there's only about five or six
like incredible records on yeezus every
other album the first six records on his
[ __ ] is incredible
jesus is like caviar bro
it's not for everybody that's jesus is
like four four four
when you say it's not fair better you
might say that
444 is a great album i think 444 is
jay-z's worst album
that's just me i can name 10 other
albums that are better i think magna
carta holy grails is worse album i
thought that album was a steaming pile
of dog [ __ ]
it's like but i mean that might be what
you want to say you know what albums is
most left on album that gets all the
hate blueprint three
that was the double album that was a
double album but that [ __ ]
i like that blueprint two blueprint two
that's what i meant to say blueprint
three was terrible too
it was blueprint three blueprint three
had j cole on it it had a
empire state of mind on it oh yeah yeah
yeah i had the song with pharrell
that's some [ __ ] had to join with
drake on there too
yeah i mean empire state of mind is
biggest record
but yeah i didn't like blueprint three i
didn't like magna carta holy grail i
love 444.
blueprint 2 had some of the best jay on
it ever but it also had some of the
worst remember how you said wayne had a
tough decade yeah
what albums did jay-z put out last
decade when did american gangster come
out
in 2007. it didn't come out last day
that was a great album
but i just wanted to go back i remember
you said wayne had a rough decade okay
i'll give you that
so listen to the last decade 4 44.
great album nominated for a grammy um
watch the throne great album
you said that album was a rack of dog
shits magna carta hilly grill was not a
champ
i like that that was a good i like that
though not for me sir
tom ford and all that [ __ ] i'm right a
little deeper though what else
what else came out from hope this decade
i was not a fan of the beyonce album
but then again there's people who think
that that [ __ ] was incredible and i'm
like i don't hear i mean i mean i like
the few songs on there i like the few
songs on there
oh yeah come on come on the j electronic
we came out in january that [ __ ]
broke overwatch jay electronica for a
whole album
i mean i don't i don't i i like i like
some of the joints on there
you don't like 444 i didn't say i don't
like it
you just say it's worse to me i can't
put 444
above and this is just me having a
regular convo because i'm a rapper so i
probably shouldn't be talking about
other rap [ __ ] like this but
i'm a fan so it's like reasonable doubt
yes in my lifetime value one
uh in my lifetime volume two streets is
watching
volume three so you don't put 444 above
volume one
uh you said do i put 444 above volume
one yeah
volume one is imaginary playmates lucky
some great stuff on there streets is
watching the city is mine a million and
one questions
you must love me no i don't you want me
to go to volume two
no volume two i mean listen i i i love
volume three neva
12 am on the way no volume three is
there's been a murder
dopamine with juvenile your dope man
remove your roof [ __ ] let the sun shine
in no it's not better than that one
neighbor you wanna go to the next one
it's not better than a black album
neither it's not better than a public
service announcement
and no no i think black album is the
lucifer [ __ ] that kanye wrote
i think black album is i think there's
only
there's three right answers let's keep
going through these albums what's your
favorite album
oh blueprint we forgot about blueprint
blueprint what's your favorite jay-z
album blueprint
that's fair that was i think because i'm
born on september 11th
so i remember uh when he put that album
out him and fab
i think
yeah i remember just putting blueprint
on and the city new york was in like a
real
funny it wasn't like a real funny area
right
and uh i remember the rulers back
[ __ ] uh
uh song cry never change
all i need you know what i'm saying the
[ __ ] with
safe to say though eminem had a better
decade than wayne quality of music wise
would you would you
well actually yeah oh wait yeah so 08 is
one yeah so i would say you know the
last 10 years if we had to stack up
music it would be close
yeah every every like i said everybody
got their drop points you know you said
you ain't like the beyonce [ __ ] and you
ain't like the magna carta holy grail
a lot of people like manna carter holy
grail i was not one of them a lot of
people like jesus
i was not one of them that's fair
most people don't like you i think and
then bring this whole thing first this
whole conversation because i don't want
nobody to get this misconstrued like i'm
[ __ ] on people i'm a fan of
all of these people that we talk about
that's why i can go this in depth in a
conversation with you about it
and not sound like i'm kicking dirt on
them and not being able to praise them
in the same token
right you know what i'm saying um
a lot of a lot of artists that we've
been talking about today
they went through errors of [ __ ]
changing mm-hmm
you know what i'm saying i think a lot
of times we overlook that too prime
example of pusha t
how we was talking about like lord
willing and then
uh then when his brother went to do his
thing so now they're not the clips no
more you know what i'm saying no half no
fury is their best album
yeah that was hard too and then it's
like then we seen him on the vmas with
yay
like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] might be dope
yeah you gotta
spit it but where is this gonna go then
we seen where that could go he had to
reinvent himself from lord willing
from my i don't love her i'm very happy
that pusha t
has yet to reinvent himself he's still
rapping about selling cocaine
no but i mean when i say reinvent
himself when i say reinvent himself i
mean to a new
era to a new demographic you know what
i'm saying because
i was young listening to the clips
so for me to be grown and a [ __ ] from
the clips
still looked like the [ __ ] from the
clips in 98 don't even really look like
he aged but
they [ __ ] with him right now they
listening to him you know what i'm
saying it's the same thing with
lil wayne he was lil wayne he was on
songs with sammy and
and little zane right strike one you
know what i'm saying
wow and [ __ ] like that right he went
through
errors like lil wayne went through the
kitty era the
you know then the the teenage era the
getting a little older era then it's
like oh now he's like one of the top
artists so now he has the top artist
like if you look
at all them [ __ ] errors he went
through like we were talking about snoop
no snoop for sure snoop got errors of
[ __ ] they got errors of [ __ ]
yeah yeah you got errors of [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying like from album
alma you were saying
[ __ ] changed whether it was somebody
coming in with a sound and he liked it
and he latched on to it or whatever it
was
it worked he did it a lot of people
might have tried to do that [ __ ] and it
didn't work
cause a lot of people that tried to do
the sounds that other people did or was
popping at that time
they couldn't make it work for them you
know what i'm saying so same thing with
rick ross
i remember seeing ross in a [ __ ]
trina video for the
all about the benjamin's movie that's
great with no beard
right told y'all how to get down uh
he was out then but he went through
errors
when i'm when every damn hustling came
out
it's a totally different everything now
definitely it's a total different ever
than now
you know what i'm saying he still got he
still got us wanting to hit that fly
[ __ ] he still got a [ __ ] like me
waiting like yo when roy's gonna do
album with justice league
oh yeah that'd be great i need 15 rick
ross
tracks over justice league type
production you know what i'm saying
so your album is out what panel was
out right now man uh i wrote it
recorded it mixed it shot all the videos
edit all the videos
shot the documentary editor
you you handled the whole [ __ ] handled
the whole [ __ ] man i just had my homeboy
master it because i was like sometimes
it just sounded a little
a little here and there but that's what
i'm trying to get into i'm trying to get
more into the
the visual aspect of it i know i'm nice
you know i'm not
and that's not even to be on no cocky
[ __ ] but i know i'm nice
i know i'm dead [ __ ] nice but that's
not enough for me right now mm-hmm
at one time maybe it wasn't enough you
know what i'm saying but right now
i want to be known for more than just
being nice you know what i'm saying like
that's why i'm getting into the videos
and directing and [ __ ] like that not
saying like i just want to come some
video direct
doing documentaries and [ __ ] now rap no
more cuz rap is my first
this is my love like i feel like we're
in an arrow now where you don't gotta
retire as a rapper
right you just put out music whenever
you feel like it whatever you feel you
know so that's what i kind of did with
this one
it's available wood panel walls uh
i got vado on there uh i got cars on
there
got my brother rale on there um anthony
king
to do singing on the high rollers i got
him on another journey on the project
too
cars from dreamville yeah yeah trying to
trying to just
do what i do you know what i'm saying
because it's real we're in an era where
it's real easy to go in the booth and
just throw a bunch of plugins on your
[ __ ] and try to get that right melody
right but not really
say nothing but just get the right
melody and do that for two verses you
don't even need three verses no more
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying so my
[ __ ] is more i just go talk your [ __ ]
there it is i'm saying that's all you
gotta do is talk your [ __ ] you ain't
really gotta
just like you told me last week ain't no
sense are you making too much club [ __ ]
cause we ain't in the clubs
mills where i'm gonna play the music at
well don't matter
so at this point man [ __ ] is just
spitting man i'm i'm
i'm glad that the industry is where it's
kind of at right now
because it's kind of like open field
right now you don't know who gonna beat
them next [ __ ]
you don't know who gonna be the person
that reinvent their self
and do some two-chain [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying just pop up and be like damn
he's been around for
years right all right we just starting
to am we late
it's gonna be a lot of artists like that
because right now
it's just down time man like how we was
talking before i feel bad for a lot of
artists that was at the high points
and now this [ __ ] [ __ ] them up like we
were talking about rowdy and
roddy rich russ you know what i'm saying
the whole grizzle this [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
get well to benny too you know you shot
him he's doing this [ __ ]
yeah man it's like [ __ ] we want to get
back on the road we want to get back out
there
but if you're a person that make that
type of music
right now this [ __ ] might be a little
it's a little sketchy because there
ain't really no way for us to feel that
vibe right but if you're a [ __ ] like me
and you just talking some [ __ ] you
painting pictures with these words
all you really gotta do is sit down roll
up a blunt pour something or just sit
there
cuz people are listening yep they got
their headphones in right now
they're in their car that's what i'm
doing boom i'm listening to
you know i'm listening to everything too
right now a lot of new [ __ ] too there's
so much new [ __ ] out you kind of got
time to
kind of got time to fish right right you
know what i'm saying talking about
discover [ __ ] we appreciate you pulling
out man i appreciate great comments let
me come here and talk all of this [ __ ]
about a bunch of rappers that's gonna
think i don't like them
but i just appreciate uh once again i
appreciate you letting me come to
chop it up with you all good man talk
some [ __ ] promote the product by the
time this is out the freestyle will be
out so
go check out the freestyle oh yeah
orange face out of here man it's crazy
go check that out man yeah bullet cat
podcast wrapping up
jay mills